Moe moe boo!
Okae nashaimasu!
Hello everybody!
Wait a second.
Let me adjust my screen a little bit.
That's better.
Hello!
Dispatcher mint.
Yes, that's me.
I'm the dispatcher.
It's me!
We saw you watching Nimi premiere.
Yeah, I had to watch, I had to finish watching Nimi beat the
Outer Wild DLC, of course.
Of course, of course.
I am the one who dispatches.
I can't stop thinking of breaking bad.
Welcome back, everybody.
Thank you.
Combo, thank you.
Hope you're feeling better today.
i was painting today and i spilled my bucket of paint on the
carpet no wait one time i did that though luckily like my
maid cafe is pretty abandoned but there was like a carpet
carpeted area and i and and there was it wasn't i guess any
paint is bad but it was like a big blotch of black paint i
didn't notice that it had like leaked or spilled over it was
all just, it's just a big old, big old, big old pile of
black paint in the middle of the carpet.
Oopsie.
Whoopsie poopsie.
Really broken bad by that finale.
Yeah, yesterday I watched the finale of Breaking Bad.
So, I've been thinking about it.
Tomorrow, I think I'm going to watch the movie.
better call Saul whenever I feel like it whenever I feel
like it baby blue it's cathartic the movie is pretty intense
is it how what why are we why are we why are we more intense
than the show or why are we continuing the intensity
pluribus I think I will watch it I think I will try watching
it i heard some people really like it i heard it i want to
try it so can we recap the choices you made last time in
dispatch absolutely a psa for anyone related to beef if your
chihuahua is fat enough to be confused with a corgi put them
on a diet that's right we have beef the dog okay last time
on dispatch Last time on Dispatch with Mint Phantom Um I I
fired The bat I fired the batman You cut coop I think that's
really the only thing that I Only definitive thing that I
did.
Yo, Miss Vento.
I can't go cook today.
I have dispatch, yo.
Yeah, I can't believe Jesse left.
He left New Mexico and became...
He came here.
Did you steal a kiss?
Yes.
Yeah, I'm pursuing...
What's her name?
Rabbit night.
Welcome to a membership.
cute.
I am pursuing, I am in pursuit of the, um, uh, the criminal,
da-da, aka, um, what's her name?
What's that girl's name?
Blonde blazer.
Yeah, I'm in pursuit.
I'm in active pursuit.
Invisigal.
No, no, no, not her, not her.
She's fine.
Invisigal is the criminal.
It's a criminal that she stole my heart.
You know?
Wait, you're confusing me now.
Wait, why am I confusing you?
I am pursuing blonde blazer.
I called her a criminal because she stole my heart.
But I'm not going after the actual criminal who is Invisigal
Joker voice It's simple, we fire the Batman That's exactly
what I did Okay though I fired him because For my staff Oh,
dang.
I really should have not taught him how to fly.
But for my stats, what was her name?
Coupe?
Coupe.
Coupe was better.
For me.
So I just had to...
What if I want like a whole team of baddies?
And they're all like super hot women on my baddie team.
I almost don't want to watch.
Like, you know what?
You can...
Maybe...
You don't always have to say everything that comes to your
mind, you know?
If you don't want to watch, you don't have to.
That's A-OK.
Gollum is baddie.
Yes, yes.
A whole team of beautiful ladies and gollum.
When do I get to kiss that guy?
I hope so.
In the extras, you can see your past choices.
Oh!
Choice stats.
Oh, yeah, I did that.
Yeah, I definitely kissed her.
Why is it so slow?
It kind of makes me...
Woo!
Mid-time!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Um...
Oh, yeah, I let that guy drop.
He was not upset.
He was not... He was upset with me.
Your success rate in the fight with talks was 88 percent
yeah i did pretty good um episode two yeah i fist bumped
that guy that was a very important thing i feel like most
people be fist bumping the guys good um yeah i was nice i
covered for invisigal i'm i'm such a i'm such a hard ass
with a heart of gold you know is that what normal guys do is
if if you are at the urinal and someone is asking for a fist
bump would you is that like normal bro code behavior no oh
then why did most people choose it skewer good night what
why did that even why did it so why it was a 93 percent
Popular.
Video game.
It's a sign of peace.
Royd is special.
He's a bro.
It's fiction.
I thought art imitated life.
But clearly not.
Oh.
Okay.
I understand now.
We do.
We do a good job at that.
Separating.
real life from fiction, from fantasy.
This is a game of superheroes, everybody.
It's fantasy.
It really, really depends on who asks for the bump.
Oh, really?
Riz, thank you for the super child.
Okay, um, the rock.
If he asks for you to fist bump him, would you?
The rock?
No.
A lot of Okay, what about Dwayne?
What about Johnson?
What about Dwayne Johnson?
What about the?
In the real world, the urinal rule prevents this from
happening.
The urinal rule?
It's rule number one of speaking in the men's bathroom.
Speaking in the men's bathroom.
What about Rock the Dwayne Johnson?
Um, who else?
Big fan of Johnson.
Um, what if...
Okay, I was going to say Pliskin, but that would be like an
obvious choice.
Everybody would say yes.
What?
I have to think of real life people.
What if Ryan...
Ryan...
Geisling.
He's the liked one.
Extra civility.
What do you mean though today?
Yes?
I'm seeing some no's.
Just Ryan.
Kiana Reeves!
What if Kiana Reeves asks you to fist bump him at the
urinal?
I think that's a resounding yes.
I think everybody would say yes.
I would say yes.
What am I doing at the urinal?
Maybe.
I've walked...
I've forgotten my glasses.
I walked into the wrong bathroom.
Fury of a thousand sons to those who interact there.
I just woke up from a nap.
Hi, Minto.
Good morning.
Good morning, Minto.
Minto.
Okay.
I think I'm understanding.
I'd hold it for Kiano.
What does that mean?
Like you would not go to the bathroom?
It's not good for you.
If you have to pee, you have to pee.
You don't take the urinal next door.
You always maximize available urinal space to maintain said
rule.
Our boy Robbie made a technical foul first.
Holding it.
Yeah.
Like, I'm holding it.
I gotta pee.
I can't.
hold it any longer.
It.
The clown?
What was that guy's...
Would you...
Are we fist-pumping?
It?
The clown...
What's that guy's name?
What?
What is his actor's name?
Hmm.
It.
The clown.
Actor.
Pennywise?
No.
But, uh, Bill Scarsguard.
That's the new guy.
That's the one I was thinking of, not Tim Curry.
Real friends help each other aim.
No, oh.
No, wait.
Isn't it like a battleship?
Wait, Ratatouille.
Where you are like holding, you are controlling their hands
with their hair.
Need to pee?
Go piss, girl.
I want to watch Gossip Girl now.
XO, XO.
Go piss girl.
What else did we do?
Oh, yeah.
See, I let Sonar meet his hero, and it went great, and then
I fired him.
So honestly, I think he was really okay, because I let him
meet his hero.
You...
Oh, your most sent hero was Sonar.
Maybe I should have kept that guy.
His calls were a yellow super chat.
Wait, maybe I should have kept him.
But this was...
This was episode 2.
This was in episode 3.
In episode 3, he kept getting caught by...
By, like, the sexy traps.
The men's room is, like, that gas...
scene from
the movie.
Even if she's a bully and a hater.
Who am I hating?
Who am I bullying?
What do you mean?
Tom didn't bully.
You and 37.
Look, you guys are getting a new experience, okay?
What am I supposed to be like the rest of the 70% of the
world, the closer to 60% of the world, that kept him on the
team, you're getting a different experience from the Mint
Phantom channel.
63.
Shut up.
I rounded up.
Am I supposed to be like everybody else?
I'm my own ghost.
That's why I'm dead and you're alive.
Because I don't follow the status quo.
You with...
Oh no, this one I do regret though.
But he needed to learn a lesson.
But look at this.
I feel really bad about this one.
I don't feel bad about this one.
I feel bad about this one.
We're gonna be good to Gollum this time.
He's gonna be our bestest buddy.
How time flies Weep King Thank you Oh hi Minto Off to work
today Good luck There's so many dispatch streamers But there
is only one Minto Look You probably would have never seen
This sad Sad little cute face If I hadn't done that I'm
giving you a new experience She's not like other girls She's
worse.
I can't help it.
I can't help being dumber than the rest.
Two things to keep in mind on percentages.
Since some choices are three or more, your choice can seem
like a minority when it's actually a plurality.
The game counts replays for percentages.
It counts replays.
Then that would skew everything.
ViviCore, thanks so much for the five gift days.
Wait, so the numbers don't even matter?
Oh, huh.
Ever seen the video of the guys in the urinal helping each
other while smoking and drinking?
I don't think I have said that before.
I don't think so.
Who has more kissable lips?
Sonar or Gollum?
I mean, Gollum has a lot to spare, baby.
Look at that.
Also, It's all natural.
You and 99% of players help them visit Gal.
We said 64% said we're all Phoenixes.
32% said F them stars.
Fizdom!
Thank you so much for the fight.
Get the D-Killers!
Out of the five times a hero was sabotaged, you helped them
escape with no injuries.
Four times.
Look at that win rate.
Let's go.
F them stars.
9% of...
Look, I did the whole thing with Punch-Up and Coupé and the
Fighting Club.
We had to keep her.
The UN88% of players successfully protected Victor and
Vazlav.
Is that guy going to come back?
And look, my most sent hero was Malevola.
We didn't even need Batman.
We didn't need that guy.
On to episode 4?
Let's go, baby.
Okay.
the parts that matter what is that silent hill btm this hold
on though that sounds like silent hill doesn't it all colors
thank you so much for the five gifting Bjorn thank you so
much for the five gifting thank you he prepared a mule wait
what are we doing well actually I just realized my sound was
really high up oh my goodness it saved me when Thank you for
the gift.
Am I allowed to be down bad for Malevolo?
Yeah, I think so.
Every choice Minto made is correct because cute.
Episode four.
Resume.
I don't want my ears blasting.
Am I gonna go deaf?
Oh!
Uncensor, I need to uncensor right now!
I need to get into the settings!
Is it Invisible?
Wait.
Who is that?
Huh?
She...
She thinking about...
I don't think that would be my reaction waking up.
I think...
Wait, has she?
Wait, do we need to change course?
No.
No, stick with the...
Eye on the prize.
Robert, thank you so much for the five gifts.
She doesn't...
Kitty!
She doesn't regret it.
Breaking up with...
Ah!
Oh my god.
That's terrible.
Please remember your password.
I'm turning it down.
I think she enjoyed that dream.
Ghost of commitment.
When I love a girl, that's all I could see.
She was tied with sonar.
Never understood why.
But then again, I don't know a whole lot about demonic shit.
That's a thing, right?
Oh, that was his screech!
Best to keep an eye on her.
My bad.
The only cutting one of them is now you gotta deal with
their pissy friends poisoning the rest of the team.
Harmless.
It's harmless.
Oh, well, thank you so much for the fifth to get to take
here!
Don't even think about it.
That's why I would have cut them all.
Yeah.
Cut them out.
Cut them all.
Why is she staring at you?
Don't you got some work?
She's...
Don't you got some dementia to onset?
She's so too dirty.
Hey, uh, Blazers looking at backfilling your open spot with
Phenoma Man or Waterboy.
You should think about who you want.
poster boy of SDN and the other guy pukes water.
What am I missing?
No, I love Water Boy!
Oh no, he's sad because he got broken up!
Oh no!
Rick, he looks rough.
We're gonna go with Water Boy, though.
I learned that Water Boy is voiced by a YouTuber I like.
Hey, I was watching that.
Oh, sorry.
Looks like there's no wrong answer.
Joel Haver, yeah, yeah.
I like his skits.
I didn't hear it at first.
That's a Chihuahua.
What is this?
Someone's printing their Dojin shit at work?
Hello?
I don't want to go with Famama, ma'am.
I don't like that guy.
Good out there.
even though his stats are probably like crazy good we good
all you mecha man I'm
gonna I feel like I have to replay this off stream but
uncensored the sensor bars are too big I need I need a
little bit more from my imagination complex motion we onto
something bro this is it what's a shadow box this is gonna
be it Oh!
Oh yeah!
Make a man!
Oh!
It's goatsy with Robert's face.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh!
Fired moist critical to higher critical moist yeah
oh my gosh she's just spying she's looking at his booty did
you just give me an uptown we take one she's checking him
out and use them for catch the other by guy only good thing
Is she allowed to be in there?
Okay.
Do you ever jerk off in this thing?
You low-low, Vizzy.
All the time.
I should really be asking how often.
Hey, come on.
I gotta work on this.
All the time, actually.
Bro.
I like to bus after every big bus, you know, and I was
pretty successful, so you can imagine.
Sounds like loads of fun.
Oh, they're flirting now.
Oh, no.
Oh.
You two got one weird energy going on.
She doesn't even know that she had that sexy dream about
him.
Can you handle this deep revelation some other place?
I got work, yeah?
Robert was just leaving.
Weeks of fun, weeks of fun.
That's going to be tough.
Because Blazer sent me to get you like half an hour ago,
so...
Stay invisible while doing the checkout.
Sorry if I missed...
Sorry, Bin, that I didn't get to see what your super chat
said, because it went fast.
I'm sorry, but thank you Shit blazer sorry, um, you know,
why don't you knock don't worry.
I got this thing tonight and they were supposed to send the
dress yesterday This isn't why you're here, but can you zip
me up?
It's a guy's by the way they make me wear it and it's back
in the bag by midnight What is happening today?
What's that everybody wants me the thing you're going to SDN
sponsor everybody wants me gala thing radiant valor a night
of triumph why does that sound like a propaganda rally there
thank you yeah it does kind of sound like some sort of
fascist themed oh oh oh they were making alterations all
morning uh i'm a girl's girl alarm but a little bit of your
uh ariola i'm a girl's girl like a slight hue shift oh i
don't think i've heard someone say ariola out loud before it
doesn't come up a ton now why didn't he just say nipple all
right for real now how do i look the breakup story is out so
incredible attention that i'm comfortable with i think you
look incredible let me see it i was supposed to be going
with him lawn blazer will remember that you guys if you ever
see a girl i know it's really embarrassing but like most
girls would appreciate i've had to fix i had to tell girls
that like their skirts were accidentally tucked into their
underwear i've had to tell girls that they had like you know
like their period started and stuff you know it's like i
think he could use some and if you have to have a friend
that's a girl like tell them to yeah so many people they
would be way more appreciative than not it's close mostly
i'd like you to get him out of the parking lot this guy and
tell him to stop with the edible arrangements he keeps
sending them but with All melon.
That's disgusting.
I'll see what I can do.
Oh my god.
My man never played a facade.
Hey, you're a phenomenon man.
How you doing, bud?
I have been better, Robert Robertson.
The blonde blazer and I have ended our relationship.
Yeah, I heard about that.
I'm sorry for your...
Honestly, though, I've never received that edible
arrangement.
I've always wanted one, though, because I just love fruit.
I should order myself one.
What's the occasion?
Hunger.
I'm holding all its energy and casting this planet into
infinite darkness so that I never have to see her or anyone
else ever again.
Maybe then I will be free of the torment in my soul.
And maybe then I could quiet my mind to these destructive
thoughts.
Please don't.
Bro, listen to MCR once.
We like it how it is.
Yeah.
Do you?
These days I find its ability to rise each morning
irritatingly optimistic.
Oh my!
Do you think there is someone else?
Perhaps another lover could be the cause of all this.
Maybe she met a person.
An actual person.
She didn't like me like that though.
I just resemble one anatomically.
Tell him?
No.
I don't think there is, but even if there was, wouldn't that
just make you feel worse?
He's gonna kill me.
I prefer when problems have solutions.
You guys, we didn't know that she was dating someone.
Man, her feelings aren't a problem for you to solve.
Blazer makes her own decisions because that's what people
do.
She's her own person, and she decided she doesn't want to be
with you.
That's the fact that I'm not a person is contributing to my
confusion.
Yeah, listen, you know what, while we're at it, no more
edible arrangements.
You guys are being a little dramatic, okay?
It's okay.
It seems I have much to learn about people.
You guys are being a little...
Okay, I missed a thing.
It's all right.
I'm playing the game for myself.
I'm going to pause because I don't want to miss the whole
conversation.
I don't know why the backseating is so crazy.
It's so sorry that I did not make the correct choice, but
I'm sorry.
I'm playing.
I'm just making my own choices.
so yeah let's let's calm down a little bit okay okay well
actually no not any time just just sometimes occasionally
barely any it seems the velocity with which I sat up has
shot shards of glass into your chest oh dang we're bleeding
for real shit I think it's pretty boring if somebody plays
the game the same way as everybody else does so you know I
think if you want to watch someone play the same route over
and over again you could go watch another person that
already played that job would have me bleeding this often
what are you doing here I had a dream last night that we
were fucking oh wow she told him usually I don't remember my
dreams but this one was pretty vivid how how I didn't
finish.
Not what I asked.
I don't know.
That's not what I saw.
So this is why you've been acting so weird all day.
I'm doing that thing where I imagine being with someone, you
know?
See how it feels, how it looks, you know, like trying on a
dress.
You were there.
I could have been.
Oh, my God.
Of course she was.
I could be anywhere.
Oh.
No, you chose to be here.
Oh, sorry.
I tried not to...
I tried not to do that.
Don't worry about it, Waterboy.
Bathrooms are for shitting after your first coffee and
taking shrapnel out of your chest.
Not for whatever this is.
She's flirting with us.
You ruined this for me.
It's... I know.
I know.
No, Waterboy.
Where's my Waterboy route?
where's my water boy route
my boy just just had a cuppa and it got it hit him the wrong
way it happens to everybody
oh we're dispatching let's go also stop feeding that dog
he's gonna become like he's gonna be half my weight wait i'm
zero half your weight that guy's skinny can't believe
sonar's gone this is a load of shite i have to remember how
to play this game what is this oh okay this is we have the
thing here i am glad you're still with us thing here i am
glad as well strange okay let's go out of the dorm yeah you
guys okay time to block in everybody all right we gotta load
heavy furniture and carry them down two flights of stairs so
we need someone we need someone strong
Flambé can handle this.
All right, so thank you so much for the thank you.
Thank you.
Which one?
Okay, this is Vigor.
Is it Vigor or Combat?
I feel like Combat.
I see this and I think Strength every time.
Beef is going to have diabetes and a clogged heart.
No!
First we diss, then we patch.
Let's dispatch!
Oh my god.
He's like our best bet, for real.
vigor means strength oh for some reason i see this and i
think stamina okay then golem is our man you should have a
backup plan no no you're so good i've been hearing a lot
about some guy named chad i think he's trying to demon but
wasn't there a cult of chad chad yeah chad chad chad oh my
goodness uh sam wait join the Oh my god, hello?
Is this SDN?
I was driving along the coast, and this guy in front of me
just drove right off the side into the water.
That would make Minto equal to dog dog.
Dog dog.
Dog.
I sent a soup earlier.
I was giving every Ibu going PP a fish bomb.
Don't worry, you get a special one too.
Thank you!
Dog dog, dog, dog.
Okay, we gotta rush people to the hospital, so we need...
We need you.
Or, wait.
You're just guessing.
What's resuscitate?
Would that be an intellect thing?
You know how to do it?
You're like a smarty pants and you know how to...
To...
Do CPR.
So let's do these two.
I think this should be good.
We're gonna join the cult.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, join the cult.
yeah yeah pretend to be interested no we're not we're like
actually we're pretty interested i'm gonna enjoy the cold
listening at work it went to say play how you want me though
there's no right choices i feel bad that you felt like you
needed to quit whatever or not quit but like stop whatever
you were doing to send that i mean first of all thank you so
much for the super chat thank you so much thank you thank
you thank you the other option it was uh what was the other
option it was um send malevola but i want to join it we sent
someone in have them pretend to be interested in joining the
cult yeah i think we could send both of them honestly
malevola exclusive option i guess that's true i forgot that
they do that don't they okay let's malevola do you know
where this church is located you can take a look and oh not
interested
I say She's mad at me If I asked her to go now Look at that
You go whether you want to or not You go Whether you want to
or not Yeah
That was Competent Competent Yep What's it going on here?
have boiled over into a full-on fistfight.
Return peace to the football game using your firsts.
Alright, time to get it.
Time to get it.
Does someone need a bait?
Yeah, remove the troublemakers.
Alright, the two of them are perfect for it.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Disrupted.
What happened?
The driver is out of the car but isn't responding!
Fly the to the hospital wait i didn't teach her fly did i i
taught that to sonar wait a second did she know
she can still fly okay fly him to the hospital it will be
done
drive better next time so she just she just could have
learned to fly better Oh my goodness.
Oh my goodness.
What's happening here?
They want us to drink blue liquid from a chalice as a
loyalty test.
Power through it.
You can just see what it is.
Oh.
The vibes were off on that one.
I can do better.
Oh.
Okay.
I'm having to remember how this game plays.
My bad.
Hey, this is Jason.
They're fine.
They'll be okay.
Someone just dropped off a box of games at the node saying
there's a bomb inside one of them.
Oh.
Can you send someone?
Oh, we have one guy.
He's got it.
Wait, what's the other thing?
What's this one?
Where the hell did you go?
Job's not finished, dude.
We need you to bring everything up to our new place.
What?
Oh, my God.
Are you kidding me?
Okay.
Coming through.
He's got to go back out.
Wait!
Everybody else is returning.
Okay, we'll wait.
Okay, we'll wait for them to return.
Oh my gosh.
Do I have time?
They're resting?
Oh my gosh, wait, wait, wait, wait!
I have a coffee!
Can't catch many of your streams live, but I...
Make sure to check out the VODs.
Thank you for making my work days a lot more bearable.
Crystallize, thank you!
Uh...
Oh, I do have upgrades, you're right.
Maybe...
Well, I have to still wait.
Um...
I think...
I feel like more people...
Well...
Let's make her stronger...
Or smarter.
No.
Charismatic...
More...
More charismatic.
Charismatic.
Give her the...
Give her the charisma.
Sorry, we're fine.
I'm going to give her more vigor.
Do I have time?
Okay, I do, I do, I do.
Okay.
All right, we need someone smart.
Yes.
Graceful, but deadly.
No, I think Koop's got this.
Oh, on her own.
No!
Bala, I'm gonna kill you.
Okay.
Prism.
Prism can help.
Oh, wait, you think Prism instead of...
Fine with me.
We needed another backup dance.
Oh, what is this?
When assigned to a call, Prism duplicates the hero to her
left, placing their illusion in an empty slot with half
their stats.
Oh!
Oh, that's crazy!
We need you to send somebody else.
This is too much.
Uh-oh.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, scary.
You sound like my first manager.
I fired his ass.
This is freaking bullshit.
We can't be everywhere at once.
Shit, y'all.
I can barely even be in one place.
It's clear that cutting sonar has left us vulnerable.
I can't believe I'm saying this, but Koop has a point.
No.
Can you just hang in there a little longer?
Yeah, hang in there.
Hang in there.
rub it oh my gosh okay we got we got some more upgrades too
well let me see what these are first before up all right oh
my god so many things are happening all the ones now which
game is hiding the bomb the wolves inside us man bomber
jasper's 2.5 the adventure to the return it's gotta be that
one
two feels too obvious that's how i feel this is so similar
to the other Telltale game.
This one, I don't...
What is this supposed to be?
The wolves are what?
You have two wolves inside me.
And it hurts.
I'm gonna go with the wolves.
The wolves inside us was a great game.
It really makes you feel like...
Oh right, we found the bomb.
Yeah!
What's that mean, though?
This has been my favorite game of the season so far.
I have to know.
Are you romancing anyone?
Gollum.
Um, oh dang.
They're smart.
Wait, if we destroy the we're at 10.
Destroy seems like better.
We don't need the vigor.
We need the comp or would it be bigger combat?
fist if it's vigor we're screwed oh yeah let's go nice we
kicked its butt okay what do we got going on here hey ray
here we got another tear down for you tear down coming down
and doing some demo destroy the remains of the dilapidated
house toss all the debris to clear the area that sounds like
something for someone he's heavy duty hey it's rory casey
one of my teachers called out there has to be someone at stn
who can teach a jiu-jitsu class a jiu-jitsu teach defense
guards and grapples lead sparring drills around wait lead
sparring drills ground fighting assist with reflex
development what three people for this the ceo of brand tech
milman brant hasn't been seen for days and the board is
asking stn to do a wellness check Only Sonar was here,
considering he actually fucking knows who all these assholes
are.
Well, he's not, so we're going to have to go check on the
assholes ourselves.
You handle this one, then.
Takes an asshole to know an ass...
You know what?
I'm going to put you in.
You can't reject every job, Malevila!
I'm going to... I'm going to fire you, too.
Oh, what about Kaizen?
Who?
Rejected, rejected, rejected.
Okay, hold on.
This one is the this one's going fastest.
Oh shoot We need to investigate we need some smart people
all my smarties are resting
Coupé I'm gonna I'm gonna take Coupé out.
Okay back to it.
Yeah Close your eyes You're not gonna like what you see and
then Be ready to talk him down so we need a good
I thought it said taken down, so I thought I needed my
fists.
Maybe...
What was the other stuff?
It was...
Oh, whoops, my bad.
Wait, no, I did click.
Why is it... I'm trying to close it.
I just want to see what these are.
Oh, this is the defense stuff.
Why is malevolous stats so... Why are they so bad?
Flambé for this.
Oh, yeah, I think this could be good.
Oh, because she's injured.
Oh, I did.
Okay, okay.
Minus one to all.
Oh, okay, okay.
All right.
What does fire taste like?
Pop rocks.
What more spicy?
Kind of like a spicy pop rock.
What the fuck are pop rocks?
Pop rocks.
Destroy all.
Oh, wait.
You know what?
We'll do.
I wish I wish they were good Broke her heart what do you
mean She won't even do this
She is rejecting all my stuff Oh my gosh She can stay mad
Okay
This one is going faster.
Ah!
Okay.
Good, good, good.
We got Golem.
Solid.
And punch up.
We'll do the two of them.
Hey.
Anybody got eyes on some garbage?
And...
Garbage?
Why won't you let me?
I only can choose them.
We're just gonna have to hope.
We're just gonna have to pray.
I think I'm done here.
Golem's good for soloing?
I guess I'll try to remember that for...
You're out!
Oh my god, she just actually left.
Oh my god.
She just actually left!
Okay, we're okay.
No, we're not okay!
I think it's bad out of this way.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh!
That was so unlucky.
Oh, we killed this one, though.
That's the gravy, baby.
Yippee!
Let's...
Oh, my gosh.
We're going to put you under...
We're going to give you...
You know what?
More combat to you, baby.
More combat to you.
And you...
Get...
I'm going to...
Do I have any coffee left?
No.
We're so screwed.
Um.
Flambé with the one intellect but five combat.
He's a hymnbo.
You know what?
Let's just do more vigor.
And then...
Golem!
We're gonna do more...
I love the way he talks.
Oh my gosh.
This is not good.
We need backup at the mall.
Dozens of youths just started rushing us and looting the
shops.
Catch as many as...
Oh, everybody.
I have nobody.
Wait a second.
I have literally nobody.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Catch as many as possible.
Oh no, wait.
Oh, I think Prism would have been...
Or, InvisiGal would have been good.
Oh, geez.
I don't have any coffee, you guys.
Don't ask me to use it.
What's this one?
It cleared everyone out already, but, like, someone called
us about a bomb in one of the theaters.
Oh, okay.
That's really awesome.
Um...
My IRL coffee.
I'll just go make a batch.
You know what?
I hate Charles.
I think I'm not gonna go to him.
He can...
He's a mind reader.
She has X-ray vision.
Together they are.
The ultimate invasion of privacy.
Oh, sorry.
Is this SDN?
We need help.
Protect the couple from each other.
Send someone with good people.
With good... Oh!
Good with people!
Oh!
Send someone with good people!
Okay.
Who's our...
Everybody who's our charmer.
Well, Flambe!
Ganbari!
I didn't even see that there.
Oh my gosh, we're losing everything.
Oh, this is so bad.
Yay!
Wow.
Keep it up.
Good job, everybody.
Good job, team.
Oh my gosh, which is this one?
It's time for Phil's walk.
What?
No, Phil's my dog.
Can you just, like, walk him around the park?
Okay.
Why is this a two-person job?
Is it that bad?
Okay, you know what?
I'm going to have to start soloing people, I think.
Phenomenon's still on the 405.
Just passed him.
He's gone from shaking his fist at cars to, sadly, directing
traffic.
Well, at least he's putting his newfound pain to...
Dang, I missed, like, three jobs, I think.
It's pretty bad.
blazer was such a heartbreaker is that surprising i'm just
impressed didn't think she had it in her maybe you shouldn't
be so quick to judge people gross you sound just like her
you calling me a heartbreaker in your dreams i think she's
flirting with me if anyone needs some more hands-on training
is this a this is a skill they already have right so would
they get a second skill
I wish I could have sent Gollum.
It enhances.
Second skill.
Okay, okay.
I don't even remember what her first skill is.
So let's do a second skill.
Let me do my shit my way.
What's happening?
Things are definitely getting heated.
Looks like they are about to tear the place apart.
Activate the sprinkler system.
What does that mean?
Oh, it's the hacking!
Well, that's fine.
I don't know if this will work, but whatever.
Hacker man.
Oh, what the hell is happening here?
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Wait, I think I messed up.
Ah!
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
Oh, I'm so good.
Ah!
Not good!
Wait, that scared me.
Wait!
This is impossible!
Oh!
Okay.
Ow!
No!
Wait, oh, exit?
Okay, wait, I get it.
I get it.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god.
Scary!
Okay, okay, okay.
This one dies, okay.
Oh, uh, exit.
Okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
Alright, alright.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh, whoop.
Okay, okay.
And...
Wow, they had you thinking for that one.
Look at this.
Ready, set, fire.
When sent alone, Envisagal reduces travel time and call
completion time.
Oh, oh.
If Envisagal is on the team, XP rewards are doubled.
Okay.
Oh, this is the one.
Oh, okay.
With her connections, Envisagal can reveal the number of
slots and crime type on hover for certain calls before they
happen.
Oh, interesting.
Oh.
This...
Yeah, scouting or XP.
I feel like we're gonna go with the pack.
Okay.
Because I am paranoid and I tend to send out people as teams
anyway.
So I feel like with how I play, it might be better.
Owl!
Just a little more effort, please.
Failed a call with a 70% chance of success.
Rude.
Hey, it's Jerry from Comic Pug.
We got a gift of some Mega Man replicas.
but with all the bomb threats going on we just want to be
sure okay evacuate all civilians inspect
goodbye swift as the night sharp as my knife inspect
prism nothing beats the original yeah yeah we'll do that
this will have to do prism have you finished the book i lent
you girl i'm a slow reader all right besides you promised
fairy sex and so far It has to build.
These are like the books I listen to.
That's crazy.
Search for Phil the dog.
Entice him with a friendly demeanor and treats.
You're friendly.
Right.
We're friendly.
Fairy, what now?
Oh my gosh.
I'm so glad I'm not a fairy.
It'd be so awkward.
Hmm.
Which mecha man contains the bomb?
Mecha man prime?
Mecha man astral?
Mecha man blue?
Mecha man prime?
Please say yes.
It was mecha man prime!
It was the mini mecha man prime.
It's flying around the shop and blasting.
Stop it before it detonates.
Hit it!
Yes!
Yes.
I'm confused.
I thought that would be more difficult.
Yes.
Let's see.
Um, I feel like you need to be smarter, Prism.
We're gonna increase your intellect a little bit.
To be fair, friendly demeanor and treats works with me also.
Yeah, I think me too.
I think I'm pretty easy to win over.
What do you mean he...
God away.
You better find him, man.
Oh, what was it?
Let's just do the both of them.
Aren't you persistent?
Oh my god.
They have no friendly demeanor at all.
This is so bad.
Invisigal and Punch-Up are good, but they have no charisma.
Column's almost ready.
Okay.
Gollum, and...
Punch up.
Hit it cliffside once.
Those two.
Yeah.
They'll treat him well.
Yeah, I'm so mad.
I miss so many things.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Yeah, I'm just like off my game today.
And that's lunch.
Think fuck.
Oh my god!
I'ma drink my spicy water.
That was terrible!
I knew I had a good feeling about you.
I... did I get a rank down?
Did I rank...
Did I rank down?
Or...
We ain't finding that dog.
Vagour, too?
Um...
Cool!
Invisigal.
Barely miss it, I know.
This game!
Oh my gosh, it's the Oedipus arrangement!
He's so tall.
Still working on that?
Hmm?
Aren't these the best?
I love the green ones.
The green do.
Oh, worse.
the whole thing if you want awesome my lucky day i i know
what's for lunch or dinner probably now sorry there's just
corn in the interrupting your meeting with and visit oh god
damn it you threw my noodles away my initials were literally
on the box and everything fuck i i don't read things
sometimes it's different like a logo but it's probably still
good i i don't want the
Damn!
Just aim your dick up and water piss it off.
That's not...
So mean!
I'm gonna go rinse off.
No!
How would you like to have to walk around work the rest of
the day with shit all of you?
I don't know.
I don't think about that because it won't happen.
Oh?
Oh yeah?
Because I'm not a fucking idiot food thrower away or...
It was an accident.
You don't have to be a bully about it.
You have to be a bully.
You want this in your report?
Well, you're gonna snitch on me?
At least I have eyebrows.
They're just being a soft bitch about it.
Scareddy!
Oh, am I being a bully?
Why is there spaghetti in the Chinese takeout?
Fuck!
Oh, wow.
I wasn't expecting it to go straight.
I was extra.
Sorry.
Oh, he's angry.
You're gonna choke on his fucking...
Hey, Robert, could you...
Spaghetti.
Did you eat my lunch?
Why would you do that?
Why did he throw away everybody's lunch, though?
Wait a second.
I was really hungry.
Look at him.
Why did he, he threw away like the whole fridge?
Like he's not very good at the job, I think.
Go get cleaned up.
Then clean this up.
I've gotten takeout boxes like that from Italian places.
Oh, really?
Yes.
Yeah, he threw out everybody's lunch.
Okay.
Whatever that was.
And then took the melon.
Anyway, you talk to Chase.
Who's it gonna be?
If I'm a man or water boy.
Oh, easy.
These two are my only options.
For now, yeah.
Obviously, we can revisit it.
But Waterboy is already a trainee, sorta.
And you already know Phenomen Man got cut by DTLA.
Thanks for getting him out of the parking lot, by the way.
It might also help to get, you know, an actual good person
on your team, which I'm positive both of them are.
Let's go with Waterboy.
I think he deserves a shot, and he seems shockingly more
stable than Phenomen Man at the moment.
I hear you.
Um, I might have him take care of this mess before he
starts, but yeah, let's go with it.
I'll let him know.
He really looks up to you.
Does he look up to me or...
Wait, does he know I'm Mechaman?
Yeah, but he said he won't tell anyone.
I guess that's good.
I'll let him know.
You'll see him in the roster for your next dispatch.
Aww.
I already knew who I was gonna pick.
I don't need to think about for Mamma Mam.
Are we checking everybody out?
Hey, I leave.
It's not, it's my clothes, the waterproof ish.
Ish?
Yeah, that's gonna clog.
No, no, no, no.
I do this.
See?
Oh, nasty.
This route you're doing is complete opposite of mine.
Thanks for picking me.
My, my, my.
I'm just really, just to join you.
Jassed.
The word is jazzed, and we're jazzed.
I have to do that.
I'm even reasonably optimistic that you deserve it.
See you next shift.
I mean, you might be the other way, and we don't know.
Honestly, that seems like a mix-up I feel like I would make,
though.
like I've done similar all right team hey team we appreciate
you doing your best last shift under the circumstances but
we are here to help more specifically water boy is here to
help so excuse me ain't no way he may be new to this but
Robert and I believe he will make a great addition to the
team this is bullshit good good morning evening hello this
is a joke right I don't Wait, maybe, is it a joke?
Nope, Waterboy, it's not a joke.
Cool, Leo.
Oh, oh, sweet Waterboy.
We have reason to believe that Mr. Vanderstank's life will
be in danger of the meeting.
Vanderstank!
Mobilize quickly.
Protect Willem, Willem, four people.
Holy cow.
Okay, we gotta give him a visit, yeah, wait.
Invisigal, if we succeed in this, she'll double all of the
XP.
Typical.
All right.
Water boy, are you ready for your...
What is your stats anyway?
It doesn't matter.
Golem?
Prism clone.
What is... Oh yeah.
Call me a Bogo bitch.
Oh yeah!
This might be the best thing ever!
This might be the greatest setup!
I've never seen someone pick Coupe and Water Boys in this
playthrough.
What?
Why is nobody playing Water Boy?
Why is nobody picking him?
Hello SDN, can you dispatch your cutest and talented ghost
man?
We need her for a concert this February!
Alright, let's dispatch.
Water Boy Voice.
Lick Ponging, stop it!
you don't know me uh well i i was gonna send him to the to
school but oh i have a coffee again okay awesome seriously
dude what the wait oh my god no she got injured because of
him apologize i it's my fault mistake and i get wet when
when they're nervous malevolah please to um go team with uh
me robert you cut sonar and you replaced him with the
fucking wet guy that's right you know that sonar could turn
into a bat i'm well aware how is wet guy better than a bat
well at least he can lecture people to death okay um
hopefully that doesn't hurt us so much on that mission she's
just injured so wait no she's oh she in oh i don't know okay
let's um let's get Coupé's second...
Oh wait, actually, let's see what this is first.
Hey, so we're a little down on new subscribers this month.
Think you can spare here to do some recruiting?
How the fuck are we supposed to do this?
You could try charming them with your winning personality.
Oh my gosh, Golem!
Golem is perfect for this!
Do you think he would get people to subscribe to my channel
too?
Do you think?
Water boy solo.
I got you.
Somebody order a mudslide?
Yeah, he would.
Subscribe to my channel.
Send a charming and good-looking hero to join a superhero
dating competition.
Ooh.
Oh.
Good-looking?
I think he's our best choice.
Hey, if you were a civi, what would your job be?
I feel like working at a gas station.
here.
Cool, we can do Kubei like I wanted to.
I hate pets with bad attitude.
What pets have good attitudes?
Oh, you guys!
Yes!
And he's gonna get double XP!
Oh, look at him go!
Look at him go!
Quit your day job, kid!
We're gonna make him full of vigor.
Full of of anger his thing is so tiny uh is it from amaman's
like super huge but he then like it's so sad and that's how
he sabotages you janitor moist janitor moist janitor moist
six foot four yes exactly i thought say i knew it i knew it
water boy is gonna sabotage you by accidentally being too
wet and from amaman's gonna be so sad i don't want to deal
with that i would rather deal with the wet man six foot four
wow produces water spontaneously throughout his body
crippling social anxiety easily frightened lives with his
grandpa wait a second oh wow they have so many more oh
interesting
what do we got going on here wait
Pirouette So this is the one we have On calls with With more
than two slots Coupé gains one combat If placed in first Or
mobility If placed in second Pirouette If Coupé is sent On a
call that fails She will re-attempt it Wait that's kind of
awesome If placed in the first slot Coupé now gains Plus
three combat If placed in second Oh that's tough
I feel like both are life-saving but reattempt especially on
the ones that like we have like an 80% chance or 70% and
then I think reattempt is really good let's go with that
what we got going on here
I'm gonna stay winning I'm gonna stay winning yes sir and
you're gonna become I'm gonna let's give you a little bit
more intellect so that you're like you're a little chunkier
I'm the firm opinion that Minto can never make a wrong
decision except kicking out Gollum and firing Sonar.
Also, my 25th was two days ago.
I forgot to mention it.
Love you, bye.
Syntax!
Why didn't you say anything?
Happy birthday!
The hero to put on a show?
We need Terrence the Turtle to beat someone up.
Happy birthday!
Fake fight.
The mascot during halftime.
Make it look convincing.
I think punch up will be good for this.
I used to punch bombs on that corner.
It makes you wonder if the best days are behind us.
It's time to charm.
Flirt away.
Oh no.
Oh it's time to meet the civilians.
Let's flex.
Flexing time.
Wait what?
It seems no one is interested.
What's plan B?
Oh.
Flambé!
Some bananas faster.
Hey, Flambé, you cook, right?
I'm picking up what you're putting down.
Oh!
So you finally noticed.
I'm perfect.
Oh!
Let's go!
We're gonna give you some even more charisma so you don't
mess that up again.
We've tracked down the assassin's temporary base of
operations.
Yeah, no.
No you had that option, now you do!
Oh, sorry, exit.
I clicked the wrong thing.
Oh, that doesn't seem good.
Okay, oh.
Why did I do this then?
Nice.
Maybe so I can move him there.
Right, right down!
Left, left up!
Oh, wait, what was it?
This one?
Wait, why am I doing... Why am I opening this?
Oh, because it opens up there too!
Okay.
Right, right, down, left, left, up!
Left, up, right, oops.
Left, left, up, right, right, down.
Go, go, go!
Razor Raymond, who's that?
I speak...
Bisexuals!
Yeah!
Oh.
What's this?
Water bitch almost took me out back there.
Is there a return policy on this motherfucker?
Yeah, maybe we get someone who doesn't suck.
No, he can't help us!
Take down the located assassins, identify the location of
their boss.
I think we can do the same team as before.
Oh wait, sorry, it's three people.
I for some reason thought four.
Okay, never mind, hold on.
Uh, redo, redo.
We need some smarts in here.
Take down, though.
We also need them to be fast.
Wait, uh...
Not my level, though.
Maybe Coupe.
I don't know.
But definitely.
Like that, maybe.
Invisiplus water?
I don't think...
Oh, whoops, whoops, whoops.
I don't think it'll be enough.
It's time to put an end to this.
Take down his combat.
Oh.
Hmm.
Okay.
I love a symmetrical stage picture.
Hold on.
I feel like...
if Visigal will be better.
Malila, she can heal injured.
Make up your mind.
Okay, you have to stop calling me that.
Fine.
Let's do it.
You are about to feel so much better.
And so am I.
Malila heals one hero when sent on a call together.
She then receives plus one charisma or vigor.
This effect stacks.
See, I didn't know that she could heal because I literally
hadn't unlocked it before.
Oh my god, it's almost exactly him.
Nice.
We're killing it, you guys.
We're killing it.
Hello, dispatcher.
Would you like to play a little game, perhaps?
A brain teacher.
How'd you give him my number?
this asshole careful he's tricky his name is brain teaser
brain tickler don't say i didn't warn you
the brain tickle baby kaiju attack capture the small baby
mini baby kaiju it may be little but it's still strong golem
get in there my goat chicken but capture would be speed no
so maybe we're with a coupé.
Who is this?
The Riddler.
Gollum has it?
Solo?
If he loses.
What is his set?
Wait, hold on.
What is his...
What is his power?
Because...
Expands to fill empty slot.
Increasing his stats by 25%.
Okay.
He expands.
That's what it is.
Humor the brain teaser.
Let's humor him.
Have you been paying attention?
Answer my riddles 1, 2, 3 and I will gladly Turn myself in
We need someone smart, don't we?
High injury risk
Beater beater beater beater oh, no
Baby Kaiju looks like he wants to play Adop the baby That's
a baby right now
I'm a dad now.
New mom!
Oh my god!
Wait, that's so cute!
That's so cute!
More vigor for you.
I love Golem.
What's this guy?
This is a retired SDN hero at Kryptonite causing problems.
Can you get him out of there?
Kryptonite!
Wait, that's such a good pun.
I remember him when I was a kid.
Poor guy.
How you been there?
Before I joined the Z-team, I didn't have a pot to piss in.
He had to borrow one of my...
That's such a good pun.
Attempt to cheer up and persuade the retire...
I feel like this is a good thing for...
Punch-up.
But he's got the charisma.
And withstand the beer bottles.
I think he's a bit of a kidder.
Wait, what if they go together?
No, we don't need them together.
I think...
And Koop?
That's overkill.
We'll do it.
I feel like single mamas, Minto.
We'll do them together.
They're like a good team.
I like to keep them together.
But...
Oh, yeah.
Nice.
I say that, too.
Holy moly.
Indeed.
Let's see.
Let's give her some more.
more mobility.
Let's make her faster.
And then, Malevolon.
We'll give you more charisma.
And Waterboy.
You can take literally anything.
You need everything.
We'll give you more charisma too.
Okay.
Look, he's almost...
Oh, you can't see, but he's almost to another...
He's 827 XP out of a thousand, so he's almost gonna reach
another level soon, too.
Alright.
We still gotta decide on that, guys.
Let's maybe not start a war here with an elite assassin
organization.
Try asking them to leave nicely.
Convince their boss...
Okay, I feel like I have to do Prism...
Holy moly, Flambe.
but none of they're not very smart which is the issue
bandaid prism oh i have none if i had an item you guys i
would use it but like if i really i guess like i will
honestly i could use the coffee here but i don't know if
it's like
nobody is resting though everybody's returning coming in Big
N, thank you!
Solo?
Solo with Prism?
Because we still need somebody for...
This.
Entire Z team receives XP.
We need somebody smart and...
I think Coupé would be my smartest.
Prism and Flam have a...
Have a synergy?
Let's try.
Oh, wait.
It also doesn't apply here because there's not a third.
You know what?
Whatever.
We'll see how they are after resting.
Humor?
No, she's not smart enough.
I need Coupe, for real.
I think she can do it.
94%.
Let's go!
I'm your hero, baby!
Oh, they do have a synergy!
Whoa!
What was happening?
Why is he doing that?
What the hell?
100?
How did it get to 100?
Because of their synergy?
Okay, now I can bring Coupé out.
Okay, she's gonna be our girl.
Okay, back to it.
You're the smartest one here!
We're leaving it to you!
She's the one.
Uh-oh.
Go back to wiping up spills, Janina.
We'll start an easy one.
What's my favorite game?
It's the wolf within us, right?
Or what if it's the wolves inside us because that was the
game that they technically said earlier.
I'm going with my gut.
Favorite movie.
Oh, did we hear about movies before?
Oh.
That isn't a riddle.
I know, this guy is so...
This guy is so full of poo.
It was the one you missed.
Oh, no.
I'm gonna guess Staying alive
Oh Oopsie Oh so so close We needed a tad Sorry Coupa Holy
cow
Hey not bad though not bad Not only did you cut one of their
dumb shit criminal buddies You're also forcing them to work
with An actual good person that wants to be a hero.
I was going to go with wet baby bitch boy, but yeah, we can
go with him.
Don't be mean to him.
He can't help what power he was born with.
Hey kid, love you.
Love you too, aren't you?
Don't fuck this up.
Unk.
He got unked.
He can be both.
Don't call him a bitch.
What is this?
Oh!
Why is that in there?
Oh my god!
No!
Oh god this dog is huge!
Holy cow!
He's not a weener dog, he's a sausage dog.
Hey mom!
Hey honey.
Oh they just have to rub the family in his face.
We're a place where we'll go back to EQ.
He's all beef.
Oh my god, he's really limber though.
He's jumping around.
He was flying.
Can animals get powers in this world, I wonder?
Yeah, let that dog, make that dog run.
Oh no, he's not running.
Oh, he's lazy.
Oh, no.
Oh, he's running, okay.
Maybe he's so big because he ate the thing that we're trying
to...
get fat boy plopping about I think he's so big because he
ate the thing that we need for our suit before baby kaiju so
true those they they make fun of my issue my my stutter oh
hold the beef it'll help hold the beef i don't think it's a
stutter what can you not it's happening right currently this
very right now you you can't i you expect failure worried
the more you expect failure the more likely it is to happen
yeah i don't think you have a stutter confidence issue
you're worried you're gonna say the wrong thing so you won't
finish the sentence I'm blowing your mind what are you
afraid of with the C team and seriously what's the worst
that could happen they call me useless they call me I don't
know I think I suck see they say that all the time you
worrying about it didn't stop a thing so fuck up fuck me
fuck everybody oh is that an invitation stop caring what
anyone else thinks smells very chemically in here oh my god
what's out oh no where are you she watching a movie what you
watching technically you're still on the clock uh Oh, it's
so sweet.
I love Waterboy.
That's extremely inappropriate.
Especially since I'm usually the picker, not the Peggy.
Noted.
Well, tell me how it is.
No, you're invisible.
Your name's not Peggy.
At least 20 minutes of trailers.
I always forget what I'm watching by the time the movie
starts.
I kind of like the trailers.
I'm alone or Robbie.
A rebel.
That night, feel bad asking people to pay when I'm just
going to sneak in.
Peggle enjoyers.
Floating buckets of popcorn.
Popcorn too tend to draw a lot of attention.
Oh, but I miss it.
I miss popcorn.
Ah, I want some popcorn.
Oh, I have some right here.
Chantuck, welcome to bamboo shed.
Thank you.
Oh.
Oh, for dinner?
Guys, we are so in.
Oh, wait.
See you tomorrow.
No spoilers.
Yep.
I have.
See ya.
Sorry if there's a gal.
You've had one dream of me.
Too much coffee?
Wait.
Sure.
What's up?
This isn't what I look like.
I don't tell you to know what you mean, but okay.
The powers make me...
It doesn't matter.
I'm just gonna show you.
Wait, what?
Are you good with that?
How?
I have absolutely no idea what's about to happen, so this is
very important.
exciting temper your expectations what is it what am I about
what I don't know what to expect at all
Okay, does she not have powers is it all the next the
necklace
What's going on?
Oh my god magical girl detransformation
She's oh my gosh she gonna be blue she's blue she's gonna be
blue.
She's gonna be blue.
She's gonna be blue She's blue!
She's...
Blunet!
She's a brunet!
Oh, okay.
I'm sorry.
You're disappointed.
Uh, are you kidding?
I thought I was gonna be like...
Are you joking or am I joking?
It's a big difference.
You're what?
Is it?
And a brunet, come on.
It's...
She's shorter?
If it wasn't called blonde blazer, I wouldn't be so
self-conscious about it.
and they never meet me first.
It's always the superhero.
It's hard to live up to.
We're so in.
Was
that less of a mistake than the first one?
A little bit.
I'll take a little bit.
Oh my god, if a mama man's gonna hate us.
Mandy!
Robert, it's really nice to meet you, Mandy.
likewise would you like to save some ladies for the rest of
us sorry i'm eating popcorn oh they're cute they kind of
look like siblings whoa you fancy wait this might be the
best day ever if you think it is it is did you know that the
michelin star ratings were created by the tire company they
gave high ratings to restaurants away from the cities to get
people to drive more spaghetti the way they did that i
thought it was gonna be the beauty and the beast that's what
i thought it was gonna be like a huge transformation like a
water boy you don't have to do that anymore go home water
boy go home he's allowed to go home right yes i'm not
running a sweatshop hey water boy go home we have romantic
music and everything What does he think that I could
possibly be saying that would that would make him keep
going?
You sure you don't miss the blonde?
Look, I actually prefer brunette, so this is great.
Oh, is it now?
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
If she was blue and fuzzy.
Why fuzzy?
I know.
It's crazy.
Yay!
Oh my gosh.
Got that girl!
Woo woo!
After watching Two Brunettes kiss, they look like they're
related.
Freak Phantom Strikes again.
What did I say?
I mean, it's kind of just like, you know...
I don't know.
Jesse!
Laura Bailey.
Why?
Who is she?
Oh, Invisagal!
Oh, Joel Haver!
Oh, there's the gravy man!
Robert's dating his boss, and we call you boss.
What are you trying to say?
Are you gonna self-insert as Robert?
I think Robert's a good guy, though.
You know, so...
you know let's keep going yippee you and 55% of players
added water boy to that's pretty I mean that's basically
half half I think I'm not so surprised by that you and 42%
of players had dinner with blonde blazer not too thank you
for the thank you so much thank you we got dinner baby?
Envisical?
Oh, an order of appearance.
I was going to say, wow.
They put her first.
You and 61% of players threw spaghetti at Flambé.
Is it because of the spaghetti that she got spaghetti?
I got skinny on the brain, everybody.
Mm-hmm.
Laura Bailey's husband got in trouble for picking Blazer.
You and 79% of players warned her about her dress.
See?
It's better to be honest.
I hate when my boss makes me have romantic dinners.
Oh, I know.
I'll buy you Skeddy.
Yeah.
What?
Tanoy...
Tanoy Reed.
Royd.
I hope I'm saying his name right.
The Rock Stunt Double.
What?
No way.
You and 75% of players kept kissing Blonde Blazer a secret.
Skeddy Fines.
Yeah!
You and 40% of players adopted the baby Kaiju.
Why would you not adopt the baby?
I guess if you don't send out Gollum, then.
You and 80% of players failed to save all three businesses
from the brain teaser.
My bad.
do you think they had that skeddy at midnight i would hope
not because that would mean that water boy is literally
working dispatch babies beef and bean corduroy chrysmo and
corday me meet the cat molly molly molly olly nico nico nico
nico here have skeddy it's like one of my Hero's heart is a
bowl of spaghetti.
You and 23% of players fail to answer all throughout.
It's not my fault!
I promise!
That's my man!
Mo sent out was Gollum!
You performed better than 40% of players in today's shift.
Good?
You activated Hero's powers 40 times.
Most successful hero was Golem!
Yeah, go, go!
Top 60%!
Yeah!
You sent the hero...
Perfect hero for the call three times.
Man.
That was episode three, right?
Or four?
It's in episode five?
On to five.
Okay, cool.
Rise and shine!
What are
we doing?
Oh.
I'm being Mechaman.
That's everybody.
All clear.
Mechaman!
Some training montage.
Peak cinema this episode.
Yeah, okay.
They do count people who went back and did perfect run in
the percentages, so 40% is pretty good.
Oh, you're right.
Thank you.
Oh wait, are we gonna have the QTEs again?
Thank you for helping with my cope that I'm doing a good
job.
Took him out one punch.
Uh-oh, there goes some of the foundation.
It's not Culp, it's Coupé.
But his suit is working again.
Unless this is a flashback.
Because...
Whoa!
Oh, a flashback no
you can do it get your gains you need a spotter uh-oh how
are you gonna get out of this one you're not supposed to
live without a spot idiot yeah you need a spotter so weak so
so weak oh now i'm getting a safety lecture from a walking
fireball It's a reality check normies need babysitters so
you don't hurt yourself thinking you're a hero I'm no
normies.
I'm an otaku You're the king of the normies.
I've seen fucking wet white boy put up more on the bench No
more hero stuff without supervision you can't get injured
because we need you behind that desk to help real heroes
Actually speaking of injuries remind me who burned off your
eyebrows again?
I assume it happens all the time, given your, you know, your
fire shit.
I got into a fight with an actual real, actual hero.
And I assure you, he's regretting his decision to tangle
with me.
What?
It was literally at the bar.
I imagine he's regretting a lot of his decisions.
That's fucking right.
And you.
It's time for you to accept that you don't got it anymore.
And pretending you still do is bombing people the fuck out.
Hey.
Now, get your flat ass off my bench.
There's two benches here, mister.
His butt is a little flat.
Meantom, my man, is the only hero.
Are you alright?
Flambé said you almost died under some weights.
Something like that.
Oh, is Invisigal spying on me again?
She's kind of a pervert.
I just...
I had a great time.
The other night and wanted to see if maybe you want to do a
real date or something.
Was it the plastic utensils of the man puking water on the
windows that made that less real?
there were many contributing factors yeah that'd be a date
with blonde blazer or Mandy oh I don't know which would you
prefer and that's not a trap I'm both of them we'll say
Mandy I mean if I'm pressed I think I'd prefer the girl from
the other night so yeah Mandy will remember that okay she's
like you like me behind The me behind the mask.
This kind of seemed like a trap, though, right?
Man, Dave.
Actually, maybe...
You're so lucky.
Maybe we should have said Blonde Blazer because she's taller
than us.
Kind of awesome.
Oh, my God.
What a sweet...
Oh.
Just...
Don't wipe it on your dog.
Most of my major decisions aren't common.
Really?
Nah, there's...
I'm sure it's fine.
Oh, oh, we're back into it, baby!
Wait, have some.
Yo, you ever noticed the Torrance vibe is like...
Rancid?
Between the dead fish and the harbor, the giant refinery, it
can't tell who's to blame.
Let's still punch up a little more charismatic.
I love the smell of the refinery.
I hate the smell of gasoline.
I love the smell of gasoline.
all right everybody respectfully shut the fuck up who pissed
in your cereal and smarter we need smarter people uh coupe
we're not getting brain tickled again next time all right
gasoline smells so good i can't help it all right here we go
let's go team we got our first job annual talent show do it
for the kids do it for the kids someone magnetic full of
personality has an eye for good with kids how do i know if
they're good with kids
crime not killing kids i guess i feel like prism would be
like so popular because she has like the the the followers
right charisma let's just do prism I think she'll be fine.
I guess I'll go.
I'll guess I'll go.
Golem!
You're right.
Vandastank has requested a rescue.
Vandgo workers are trapped after a tunnel collapse at the
new station.
Get them out safely.
And discreetly.
Discreetly.
Navigate the tunnels.
Save the workers before they run out of air?
Scary.
I think we need...
Envisagal, Coupe, Gollum.
Holy cow!
Oh my god!
Uh, that doesn't matter if we need vigor and mobility.
I feel like Vanderstank is one divorce away from starting a
full-on robot uprising.
Go, welcome back!
Thank you!
Uh oh.
Disrupted how?
Z team is on the scene, but it's not as easy as pulling the
workers out.
I think you can squeeze through there.
Robert.
We got Gollum.
He's doing its thing.
I know.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
The synergy.
The synergy is synergizing.
Baby, baby, baby, baby.
Let's do some more.
You know what?
I think I will start putting some more stuff.
smarts into Visigau, so we have a second smart person.
Gollum's the goal.
I love him.
He's too good.
Biddle eat it.
SDN's tolerable and inclusive workplace make you a great
sponsor for our aliens among us exhibit.
Discovered every hero's starting power.
Oh, yay.
Waterboy assigns himself when not sent often.
Oh, okay.
E-Gree.
sponge he gains plus one to the highest stat for that call
and can be alien like hero this suits him so much okay good
luck not exactly an alien per se but I think this will work
I remember my first talent show I got second place oh my so
close talent judged yay i shot a laser beam and burn all
that hair off so i guess you're the real winner then sure am
inspired my first single too let's do some more bigger
sounds like a real bop a bop what's wrong with bop we have a
crisis the parents started fighting over the results
Register!
Thank you so much for telling us.
Convince the parents and children to stop fighting.
Convince them non-violently.
Oh my goodness.
Hero training.
Training time.
It's training time if anyone's up for it.
She's so awkward, it's so cute.
Learn to fly!
Fly!
We didn't miss our chance for fly!
Oh my goodness, what's happening here?
The children are asking about living on another planet.
For Mamma Man!
Uh...
Enlighten them about life on planet 424.
It worked, right?
Oh no, it didn't work.
Nothing would have worked.
We bombed the place?
Oh my god, there's children!
Okay, hold on.
We gotta convince non-violently.
Golem.
Go.
And then...
Uh...
Outsmart the persistent stalker.
Make him disappear, but not...
Are you sure?
You sure?
You don't want to make him disappear?
Let's do these two.
And then we're gonna send...
Okay, we're gonna wait until he's done resting.
And we're gonna send a flambé to learn how to fly.
Because apparently he doesn't know how to do that yet.
No one will ever know.
What's happening?
How do you get rid of a stalker?
I'm gonna delete all his files.
I'm gonna make him so sad.
get the backups too and the backups too this is right right
left right left oh
it's backwards left left right oh my gosh
oh oh Uh...
Oh my god, the time is still going down.
Is it... right, left, left, right, right?
Oh my gosh, confusing.
Ah!
He's using protection.
Go, go, go!
Oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no.
Uh, oh shit, oh shit.
Ah, ah, what was it?
Left, left, ah!
I gotta loop him again.
Ow!
Ouch!
Dang it!
Oh.
Uh.
It's also reversed!
No way.
Oh.
Glad I remembered it.
That was so scary.
I can't do that.
He's the only victim of his.
Let's delete all the files on his laptop.
How'd this go?
Not so great.
We're fine.
Yes.
I mean, all things considered, I'll call that a win.
Yeah, me too.
What now?
Lawrence Middle School is hosting an anti-bullying seminar,
and it would mean a lot if a hero could come talk to the
students and their parents.
Mm-hmm.
This is the job for me.
Call me a BOGO bitch.
Yes, no water boy coming out.
Water boy will help them.
I'm gonna go out.
Give this performance you're all.
Oh shoot, I should have sent Prism home.
Break a leg, but not like that.
Um...
Maybe mobility is fine all right yeah go try it up do you
have a charger not on me my apartment was without power the
sun may fly so call locations greatly reducing travel time
you're in the middle of that book and everything aren't you
the fane of the sun lands was about to confess her feelings
to the prince of darkness more charisma it is imperative i
know how he responds nice yeah i get her though It's
imperative, right?
Okay, so far so good, guys.
Hey, we're getting flooded with calls about sewage in a
couple neighborhoods.
What should we hit first?
I am uniquely equipped for this looks like the job for me.
Holy cow, you guys!
Not bad at all.
How the hell did we get that?
Oh my god.
That was crazy.
too bad there's no grammy for this clutched for real i want
the 37 that's insane okay let's get you um a little more
let's get you some more charisma buddy
sewage clog sewage spill i take the kids to the beach and
what do i have to deal with huh shit there's poop all over
the beach the sewage is spilling out into the water venture
into the sewers through the sewage repair the broken pipe
causing the spill withstand the sheer force of the voice of
sewage
sewage sewage clock this should have been dealt with
yesterday before it even got this bad is there someone else
I can speak to investigate the sewers the sheer voice the
sheer voice of sewage Okay, the other one gives us...
Okay, hold on.
If I send Golem it...
Now that's doable.
Yeah, see, he says it's doable.
And then the entire team will get the XP if he makes it.
Let's try.
It's the most bullyable on the Z team.
Wait, but he's not very...
We'll find.
We'll see.
Oh, oh.
Go Go!
Go!
Actually, I'm pretty sure it's me.
Yeah, at least Waterboy can get a girl wet.
Ooh.
Let's do, um...
I'm gonna send Waterboy to Hero Train.
Better get a towel.
Oh!
This could go anyway.
Yes!
Let's go!
Everybody getting points, baby!
Oh yeah!
Let's go.
I am in need of a very specific type of hero for my upcoming
project.
Artists desire someone with an air of mystery and intellect.
Someone who is unassumingly strong.
I think Coupé is perfect for this.
Because she's strong.
But she's also so mysterious and cool.
I think she'd be perfect.
Not that I have my point shoes.
Alright, what are we getting?
Waterboy now gains plus three to the highest stat for that
call.
Waterboy no longer assigns himself.
Waterboy will heal up two heroes when sent on a call
together.
So we can have a...
we could have him stronger ish
I think having a second healer other than malevola seems
pretty nice I think I'm going to go with that one expanded
powers for four different heroes yeah all right one second
let's see actually let's see what this is first Mysterious
fire is broken out in the refinery.
We got it under control, but we can't investigate the cause
with all these dangerous fumes.
Flambé.
I would never blow up a refinery, okay?
They smell like shit.
Sometimes...
Someone's pushing up the boys' explosion territory.
Oh, wait, what did it say?
Sometimes...
So if I reach...
If I go too far, we will fail.
Search around the refinery to locate the cause of the
explosion.
Avoid dangerous fumes and flames.
flames.
I can do that.
Okay, wait, this is kind of tough.
See ya.
Oh, my guys are too strong.
Sure, I'll hang back.
Hold on.
Oh, who's the one that we got the, if they fail, they try
again?
It was Coupe, wasn't it?
Dang, but we're not gonna...
She's busy.
Hold on, I'm gonna see if...
if I can get Gollum.
Avoid?
That sounds like mobility.
And, oh, he would expand so it would make himself stronger.
Yeah, I don't want to do Gollum.
I think maybe this is our dream team right here.
Wet and ready?
No, no, no.
Wait, hold on.
Fine.
nothing beats the original but this will have to i know i
still think i still think envisagal and water boy i think so
oh man more than the hallways is you went on a date is that
true you jealous or something look if you wanted to grab
dinner all you had to do now we need more mobility
What's the nicest thing you've ever said to me?
Wow!
Rise up!
Thank you so much for the thank you!
Thank you!
That was surprisingly entertaining.
What if we're trying to set up Invisigal and Waterboy?
I'm just saying.
What if?
Okay, this is probably the last mission I imagine.
Wait!
Holy!
Yes!
Looks like the red ring was behind.
And Draco, thank you so much for the time gifted!
Thank you!
Holy cow!
They both have two!
Let's go, let's go!
Actually, yeah, we'll do more mobility.
And gorelim.
We're gonna increase your intelligence just a tad.
Good job, Minto.
Thank you!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And we're also gonna make you smarter.
We're gonna make a bunch of people smarter.
I feel like I have not enough.
Oh, wait, she has two, that's right.
And more vigor.
I don't have enough smarter people.
In fact, we're gonna do that for you too, Waterboy.
There you go.
Smart!
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
Yippee!
Big brains all around.
Wait, I had a failure?
Ah man.
I got an injury thing!
Yeah, finally.
Vigor, huh?
Let's do water, boy.
We're trying to raise him up.
I know now that I have two healers, right?
Yippee!
Don't do it.
Don't give that dog nothing.
Maybe he's got an iron stomach.
Do we know anybody like that?
Super digestion?
The glutinator?
But I don't know.
That guy would like a thousand pounds.
Did you recently lose like 700 pounds?
First off, you're either shit at math or you think I'm like
300 pounds.
I am not.
I go to the gym and I work hard.
Secondly, what are you talking about?
He lost his suit, so kinda.
Which superhero you used to be?
Person who gets his right wins 936 dollars.
That's a real specific number.
Cleric of super soakers.
Ha ha ha.
Could be house.
Just one hint.
I know my friends, right?
I'm double jointed.
what's your other superpower flipping your eyelids inside
out i wish i'd love to be able to do that i didn't like the
sound his finger made though sorry you're just gonna have to
earn your 936 dollars in some other way what way could that
be i'll let you know if i work it out did it i'm explaining
the joke what the fuck these reflexes hey beef no beef no
too much and have quick reflexes make you better than us
yeah yeah chill out dad i never had a dad i know the fuck
that's supposed to mean you told me one time you didn't have
a dad why are you trauma dumping beef shall devour all oh my
god heard the team scuffing with the red ring they run half
the crime in the county we were bound to bother them at some
point watch yourself you poke the hive you can ring yeah
that's not how bees work you know what i mean i don't
actually no one's trying to fuck shroud but if we kill the
queen we rot the hive you would do that kill shroud yes
because you might get the chance and you don't want to go in
there having to think about it you gotta know shroud killed
him chase there's only one thing i can do you know an eye
for an eye i'm not sure sure should we ask him point taken
mecha man's coming back to life one patch at a time one
patch at a time I mean Roy's doing most of these burritos is
he oh they have probably gonna redo all this I'm gonna get
my own burrito oh
we're back to work baby we got a few guesses at your
identity leading one right now is blue balls man.
Nice for an eye.
His power is not being able to nut.
His balls are literally blue, dude.
Get your head out of the gutter.
Great.
It's going to be a long shift.
Alright, team.
Okay, our first thing in the neighborhood.
A cat is out there all alone.
So scared, so hungry.
Please find my baby.
Oh my god, Kiara.
That's seriously his name.
Kiara misses her cat.
Everyone's a fucking creative.
Mr. Cat.
Okay.
I had a cat that was orange once.
His name was Mr. Orange.
So, you know, maybe we should...
Some people named their pets like John.
So...
His name was Mr. Orange.
Very fast.
Huh?
And hates people?
Hates most people.
Mr. Orange, the best name.
John Cat.
Did you provide that name and at what age?
Actually, my sister named him.
I had a cat named Kitty.
I have no room to talk.
I...
You know, with Paz, I barely call her name.
I always call her little girl.
Or just girl.
I'll be like, come here.
I'll be like, girl.
Girl, what are you doing, girl?
Where's the little girl at?
I gotta go find me a little girl.
Where's my girl at?
I barely call her her name.
I once knew this maid who was green and named herself
Maidman.
Maybe this has always been me.
Maybe this has always been.
How I am.
Probably thinks her name is girl.
Yeah, probably.
I like never say her actual name ever.
I'm always just like, girl.
Where are you girl?
Little girl.
It's like Little May from Moomin.
I love Little May.
She's like my favorite character.
So, Mr. Orange.
Reservoir dogs reference.
I don't even know what that is.
But yeah, I think a lot of people...
And then, like, sometimes I'll have a cat and...
I give them so many nicknames that I don't even say, like,
their actual name anymore.
I once had a cat named Slawbird Cat.
I think this is just normal for pet owners.
My mom was supposed to name our current cat, but because
she's the most indecisive person, kitty.
Which we shorten the kit to be somewhat original.
I don't think you need to be original.
I don't think it's going to hurt the animal's feelings.
If you're just like, puppy.
I know people who name their dogs Spider and Monkey.
Yeah, yeah.
I know people that have named their pets another animal too.
Have a cat named Tessa.
We all call her Miss Girls.
See!
Okay, let's see.
Hates most people.
Escape artists very fast.
Swift as the night.
This might be overkill, but let's try it.
It's probably overkill.
Whoa, what's happening?
Did we just lose power?
Sure did.
Citywide.
Hang tight.
We're booting up the backup generator.
Wait, was it a trap then?
There we go.
It did.
Hey, Robert.
uh-oh shit oh y'all can't see I'm a human nightlight I don't
got those problems yeah it's just a little dark what's the
fucking big deal you never closed your eyes yeah same shit I
mean I can see in the dark so this is pretty standard for me
all right fuck you guys the whole city's out guys this is an
all hands-on deck situation okay I'm gonna get a grid back
up and running be ready because shit's gonna be insane the
minute the lights turn back on.
Oh, no.
Oh, geez.
Okay.
Everybody?
Oh, my God.
I'm hacking?
Uh, restart the power.
Red ring influence detected.
Oh, no!
Okay.
Let's hack, everybody.
Wait, what's this?
Gladiator energy charge.
Over...
Wait.
Oh!
Interesting.
Oh neat!
Oh wow!
They really just like keep...
Like doing new things.
It's so cool.
Can I charge again?
Oh wow!
Oh.
Interesting.
Oh, yeah.
I need a charge here.
Oh, interesting.
Interesting.
Okay.
You got this easy?
At least it's not timed.
They give you, like, a chance to kind of figure out...
Oh.
Wait.
What the heck you're doing?
First.
I need this back.
Wait, why did I...
Wait, what?
Am I doing this right?
I don't even know.
I feel like I convoluted it a little bit maybe.
What else is new?
What the heck?
Yeah, there's no evil orb.
So true.
I've lost contact with the tower and it's pitch black out
here.
I cannot land this thing.
I know this sounds crazy.
Oh my god!
Can you guys catch this thing in the air?
Flying!
Requires flying!
Coupé is resting!
Okay, we're gonna wait till Coupé is good.
We have a couple seconds.
What is this one?
You could catch the plane on the ground.
Sounds dangerous.
Oh, okay, there's two options.
Okay, okay, okay.
What kind of burrito are you gonna get after stream?
I like breakfast burritos!
Also, hi Mito!
though.
Hi, Eric!
Um, I don't know.
I have to see what my local place has.
Light aircraft unable to land, take a risk, and then utilize
the ground team.
No, I think we... What if we make it slip and slide?
I think we got this in the air.
Wait, Coupe!
Oh, you can fly, right?
Oh, never mind.
Okay, uh, we gotta we gotta do we gotta do ground team, but
we gotta do ground team All right, water boy Okay, got it
understood You got this he's got this
Golem and prism but like But water boy
it'll be fine my pants are wet for human reasons this time
you got this go door to door in the senior community
reassure that all is well be prepared to provide medical
assistance let's see let's do we need some smarty pants so
let's do malevola and prism yeah let me finish this talk up
oh spooky Spooky!
Why is that spooky?
The tower's back on, but the refinery is still in a shit
state.
Can you lend a hand?
Oh my god, not this again.
Why do we have to be so careful?
Repairing the refinery, haul the damage out of the way.
Any delays could cause another explosion, so move quickly.
This is scary.
I don't think the refinery is gonna make it, everybody.
Um, I think it's, it's all up to you, Invisigal.
Anything could happen in a blackout.
Mostly, like, bad shit, though.
Hello.
My baby brother ate my mommy and daddy.
What?
Calm the super-powered baby.
Rescue the parents out of the pocket dimension.
What does that mean?
What is this?
The XP of the scenario will be two times.
Wait, these are getting crazy now, huh?
If we do these two...
Is that reaching?
Cannibalism mentioned.
Just send all three.
Okay.
No, I think it does.
Superpose.
Oh no, it doesn't.
Yeah, okay.
We gotta send all three.
Wait, what is that?
Oh, there's synergy.
I hope nothing else happens.
Uh-oh.
How do you stop a plane from crashing?
Ooh, we don't have either of those.
Catch the plane.
You got this.
I told you.
Oh, for real?
Just kidding.
I told you.
I told you they could do it together.
Oh my goodness.
God damn it.
The Red Ring stealing shipments right off the train.
We're not equipped to stop them.
Red Ring?
Fuck them up for me, yeah?
Secure the stolen shipments.
Defeat the Red Ring goons.
Um, one second.
We gotta do the power outage, maybe.
Red Ring.
La la la la.
La la la la la la.
Let's see.
Let's see what this hint is first.
Up, up, left, right.
Up, left, right.
Hello.
Oh, whoops.
Wait.
There we go.
Up, left, right.
Uh, I need both, right?
Yeah.
There we go.
Up, left, right.
Easy.
Uh-oh.
Maybe that was bad.
Oh, we have, like, literally nobody.
Vandals are defacing the Torrance Library mural.
there are peens everywhere.
Catch the peen, peens.
This one was fight the guys and do it fast.
I think we need to take Invisigal out.
Where do you need me?
Not here.
Oh, whoops.
No, please.
And here.
Here, here, here, here.
Waiting?
What do you mean waiting?
Yeah, waiting.
Wait, why will... Wait?
Huh?
Why?
Click the check mark.
What check mark?
Oh, oh, oh!
These, these, these!
Oh, shoot!
I forgot.
I got so into everything else.
Yippee!
The type of shit I'm on, you wouldn't understand.
Alright.
Talk about impatient.
Because I didn't finish the jobs.
I didn't make it.
After a lifetime of solo work.
Dang it.
Ah, I missed two now.
What's a good line to text a guy in the blackout?
I'm looting the Ralphs.
You want anything?
You always did the quarter in the dark.
You say boo.
Dang it.
Then we got three for three, doll.
Oh, wait, I've lost everything!
Oh my god!
They told me to call SDN.
I'm just an intern.
This is the scientist in stabilizing the serum.
Act quickly before it destroys all of torrents.
Cool?
Let's see.
Let's give you some more...
Let's do some more vigor.
She's so well-rounded, isn't she?
uh punch up will give you more uh we'll give you some smarts
we'll make you a nice fat triangle if there's a gal we're
gonna give you more mobility maxed out a hero
i i did it
i forgot oh that's right though
And then for you, we'll give you some more charisma.
Oh, Coupé, too.
Oh, my gosh.
Mobility.
Oh, so we can't...
Oh.
Was it...
Wasn't there a way to, like, reset the stats and
redistribute, or was that a skill?
I can't remember.
Jackie!
Thank you so much for the fight.
Good to thank you.
golem okay okay all right um everybody's resting so we'll
just let them do all that dang it i just oh i'm i'm really
screwed up ah that's okay though let's go oh shoot i hate
these that doesn't reach though that doesn't reach not don't
worry i got this that's good this is good yeah
Nobody 100% is this game.
It's fine.
Yes.
I'm heading downtown.
See who can use some help.
Feel free to send someone.
Let's do my level up.
Oh, it was a lot of smarts.
Oh, I think we're okay.
Oh my gosh.
I was supposed to say I think we're okay, though.
Very professional.
Holy cow.
Hi, it's me again.
You're not going to believe this, but now there's some scary
dudes with scary weapons.
I'm quitting after this, man.
I can't do this.
Red Ring is after the serum.
Prevent them from stealing it.
Let's try.
Wait, what did...
Prevent them from stealing.
Does that need to be mobile?
Maybe.
Hold on.
Maybe this instead.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, baby.
Oh yeah.
All right, let's do this then too.
Our skills.
Oh, so you do still are able to do skill points though.
Okay, that's so good.
Because I thought once they reached rank 10, you couldn't do
skill points on them anymore.
Okay, nice.
Oh.
What?
What's the point of maxing?
Why is it called maxed out there?
You can sneak in a few more levels.
Default for most heroes.
Let's do some more smarts, baby.
Actually, more charisma.
Ah, more smarts.
Just don't question it.
Okay!
I'm gonna wait until they're done.
Everybody's like working so well now.
Nobody's like, you know, nobody's sabotaging or anything.
Stop the red ring.
The tiny vial could destroy this entire city.
I think we need to fight them.
Do I even need to say it?
Consume!
I should have seen it.
I should have done that one instead.
They're all working together.
Ready, set, fire.
Whoa, oh yeah.
Let's see.
After healing a hero, Malevila also creates a portal near
the call once per shift.
The portal lasts 45 seconds after call completion.
What?
Oh, I think that one would be better.
After healing a hero, Malevila also reveals the stat of the
next call.
We'll do the portal.
All right.
I think we're ready to do the next area.
Oh no, no, no, no!
Oh!
So scary.
Holy cow.
Oh, okay, I have to...
Oh!
Shoot!
Ow!
Oh my god, that was so close.
I didn't see that guy, this guy scared me.
Okay.
Oh, he scared me.
He scared me good.
Nearly there.
Oh, he got me good.
She was so sneaky.
All right, we're fine, we're fine.
hide him behind my big head I should remember that if you
know the the room is several looting's in progress if
they're still red then that's scary red means scary oh basic
bitches out here wearing ski masks and robin banks where's
the originality these team provide back up let's see yeah
apprehend the thieves I think we could do
Punch up for the Honestly, Invisigal is so good, though
Prison for the Doppel That's what I was thinking But I want
Punch up for the Synergy We'll do the Synergy We have to
stop meeting like this I think it'll be okay If not for
these blackouts I know if the Prince of Darkness returns
Fane's feelings by now This is unacceptable.
I crave revenge.
Let a girl read her smut.
We've got other shit to do.
Let's see.
For you!
We're gonna sue some more, big girl.
Ah, man.
Easy job.
I said after I didn't...
After I missed like three calls.
High priority search and rescue mission.
for Andrew.
Andrew's very important.
Local missing, locate the missing teens.
Oh, oh!
Yeah.
Well done.
Good job, team.
What's this one?
Dude, we're sandwiched in here.
I can't feel my foot.
Major multi-car pile up.
Severe blockage, remove civilians safely to the vehicles,
push them...
Okay, so Gollum's gotta be here.
Remove them safely.
Gollum solo?
Maybe.
Gollum and Waterboy.
Nah, we'll just gollum solo.
Hey, it's like barking shit out here.
Locate the missing teens.
We'll do Invisigal.
Prism.
I love a symmetrical stage picture.
Wait, what is this one, though?
Got on the go.
Catch up to the youths on e-bikes.
Oh, thank you, Vito.
Oh my gosh, Andrew!
I'm so sorry about your missing daughter.
It wasn't you, right?
Not the e-bikes.
Yes, the e-bikes.
I think flambé is like perfect for this I think if we do
invisigal prism on the other thing Oh wait I have water boy
too I think this is perfect Wait we'll do Okay fine No he
can convince them He can convince them I believe And then
you too There we go Perfect Fire him team oh my gosh it's so
damn I think this shift gave me carpal tunnel what are you
talking about years of cranking it would get you there first
probably a combo type deal
I thought you were my good wait what happened to you you're
so He looks so sad now.
He looks so sad!
Yippee!
If you can have the same superpower of Amizagal, how long
can you hold your breath, Minto?
I'm a ghost?
I already kind of have that power.
A lot of people can't see me.
A lot of people don't have a sixth sense.
but what does that happen to hold my breath have to do with
it
I can't I don't even breathe either so like I like fake it
like I kind of like so that you guys feel more natural
watching me you know it's like how in twilight when Bella
became a vampire they were like you have to pretend that
you're breathing so that you don't scare anybody oh she has
to hold her breath to go invisible oh i didn't know that
about her oh where should we start
the pier
no sign of them by the pier the water oh yeah she does have
asthma too the beach Oh,
you found them in the lifeguard tower, but they're violently
high and refusing to go home.
We're going to be cool.
We're going to be like, hey, oh, wait.
Imagine a lecture would be brains, which we have more than
charisma.
Hi, Minto.
You look super cute today.
Warden, thank you.
would probably be smart so let's go with that oh
we didn't even need that much
oh yeah okay nice we have some more power some more skills
we're gonna do more
vigor my brain boy yeah he's gonna be smart and Vigorous.
Oh.
We're also gonna, you know what, we're gonna...
Actually...
Just more charisma.
Yeah!
Uh, oh.
Ouch.
He's gonna be unstoppable.
Absolutely.
Good week, everybody.
See you all on Monday.
Okay, have a good weekend.
I hate Mondays.
I mean, the sardines of Villain-Barre, not sure I'd fit in.
His dog is so big.
Good.
Let's fucking go, literally.
Robert.
I can hear your heartbeat.
Oh!
Go!
Someone let him in!
He's cold!
I wanna fall in love and eat pizza all the time.
Why are you out here?
Too damn big.
Do you want a drink?
No!
You want two?
Sure.
Why would they live?
Creep.
I don't know.
Get your hands.
And I don't like not knowing people.
Solidus?
Get your hands off of him.
He's the biggest perv west of the LA River.
And he's with us?
Uh, she's joking.
I'm not my business.
But if you do go jerking off in the bathroom, You make it my
business.
Whoa, cool.
I don't want to be in that business.
You made him sit outside too.
I got karmaed hard.
Oh my goodness.
This is what all bars are like.
Why do they think he's a pervert?
Is it the caller?
Is it the...
I got a...
Just for the record.
I look good.
Oh, it's a villain bar.
This ain't no Weenie Hot Jr. Please, I'm scared.
I'm SpongeBob.
Buy me a drink.
Is this for all the strings you had to pull to get me in
here?
Catch on quick.
I'll grab this a table.
Oh, that guy's looking at him.
Eagerly.
Two fancy whiskeys, please.
Make it three.
Four.
Make it fight.
Buy a fancy whiskeys now.
They're so fancy.
Nine shitty whiskeys.
Good lad.
We should have avoided him earlier.
When you thought he was a fucking knock?
He never said that.
He said he reminded me of my ex and he's not good.
Uh, you're, you're buying next.
Never mind.
Kick him out.
Cheers.
Oh.
Hello.
Excuse me.
Um, sir.
When, when you have a moment.
Take one of these.
Aw.
Do I owe this?
You, you.
Sir?
You're good.
Have fun.
Look, be honest.
Am I going to make a fool of myself if I sing Whitney
Houston?
Are you Whitney Houston?
No, say that he won't.
No, make him sing!
Make him sing!
I want to hear it.
Damn.
See, this is why we kept her on the team and not Batman.
You don't need to bribe me anymore.
I'm in your debt now.
If you ever need somebody removed.
See?
She's awesome.
Oh my god, he's waiting for his drink.
He can't have that outside.
Nice.
Ah!
He's so nice.
Look, everybody likes us now.
Oh, okay.
We have nowhere to sit.
Nobody to sit with.
This is kind of lonely.
A crunch.
We have a dream team, honestly, you guys.
Everyone thinks I'm a narc.
They can still smell the hero on you.
You're the enemy.
I bought them drinks.
What's a narc?
You can buy them drinks.
You can make sure they don't get fired.
You can line them up and blow them one by one, but they're
still going to think you might be the hero that fucked up
the A snitch, a cop!
Oh!
Currently enjoying some whiskey myself!
Let's go!
Oh!
Just tell him who you are.
What are the odds that you've busted any of them anyway?
Wow, pretty high maybe.
Ha ha ha!
Arcotics Division of Police.
Oh, so I thought narcotics, so I was like...
Thanks guys.
Come on, babe.
Is that all you got?
Come on, you out of gas?
Disappointing.
Yeah!
Oh wow, he's got a lot left.
Where's all that?
Where do you keep all that?
Where's like that store?
Don't recognize him with the eyebrows.
It really changes his character.
He should just embrace it and shave them off completely.
a bitch whose name is robert i'm a bitch yeah i'm a dick i'm
such a fucking bitch i have no hopes i have no dreams
because i'm tiny little thing and it doesn't even function
anyway i thought he lost a working in a job he was missing
him the whole time i never noticed my cat's name is narco he
was i'm glad Somehow makes less sense than what you just
said.
So, you can see, uh, why I'm worried about getting
incinerated.
We all pay for who we used to be.
The sooner you get it over with, the sooner we get a fresh
start.
You've heard me when I said incinerate.
Right.
Who let a loser-ass bitch of a hero into our supervillain
bar?
Why is everyone?
You want to die for a bitch?
Don't answer that.
He came over just to say, That's so mean!
That's so mean!
Are you lost or something, bitch?
When you're trying to get fucked up.
Um...
Since you twisted my arm, what is that one?
Well, since you twisted my arm...
No one's talking to you, fucking...
I see they finally gave you some arms.
They can reach your dick.
There's some people that want to talk to you, you piss a
bitch.
I like how it said everyone will remember that.
What are they gonna remember?
Uh-oh, everybody's bad here.
Oh, wait, it's a villain bar.
That's right.
Everyone's with the red ring.
Here.
Try this.
Are we getting tacos?
Oh, no.
Everybody got pizza.
Is the can I spent spends reporting?
It's expensive.
Can I get my money back paid, please?
Oh, man.
I want a taco so bad right now.
I ordered three triple crunch tacos.
Oh,
oh, okay.
Here we go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah!
Oh, QT!
Oh, what was that?
What was that big old...
People at the villain bar?
Yeah, don't even...
She temporarily blinded me!
She blinded me too!
Oh my gosh, please, I'm trying to play the game.
No, I didn't order that.
I ordered three tacos.
Three Triple Crunch tacos, yeah, you murdered it 50 times.
Just eat that.
It's the same shit anyway.
Given the man is three triple crunch tacos.
Hot sauce?
You drunk or concussed?
I'd go with both.
Or do some friendly fire.
Friendly fire.
I like how the way they got you ready for the QTEs.
Like this?
This is so funny to get you ready.
Oh my god.
You don't show hands after touching all them filthy
nutsecks.
Ew.
Tarty seems salty.
Ew!
Ooh, there she is.
Thanks, babes.
Source it up for me and everything.
I think you're looking for these.
Ah.
Give the man his crunchy tacos.
More QT?
E!
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Oh shoot!
There was a hold?
My bad.
I like seeing her actually like work.
It's fun.
Robert is insane though.
You still want that burrito?
This is so insane.
Oh my god.
What is Waterboy doing?
Y'all are fucked up.
Weird thing is how easy it was.
isn't as soft as his noodle arms okay that's like the
floppyest churro I think I've ever seen in my entire
afterlife Shonen protag moment yours don't start fights you
finish them oh how do you have beep with them mr.
dispatcher yeah we know this Robert guy is affluent who are
you really I'm Robert it's a rare thing in life you know
fresh start clean slate you all know every room be honest
sorry I'm Robert I walked into SDN and suddenly I was me it
was just me we have the chance to leave the past behind I
don't care you were five years ago two months ago yesterday
I care about Robert and right now and right now I'm I'm
Robert.
Are you all buying this bullshit?
He's scared.
It's a mind game.
A freaking tactic.
I do know hesitation mostly because I don't want you guys
spamming what I should do in the chat and having me
reconsider anything.
What's your problem?
I don't like not going with my instinctual first answer
because I don't want to be influenced by you guys at all.
Just let it go, bro.
Be free.
So, I'm Robert.
who are you Chad Chad you heard that I'm Chad see we're not
hiding behind our masks and our and our superhero names
we're showing who we really are my name's Courtney Courtney
nice to meet you Courtney Herm.
Herm.
Oh, Herm.
That's his name.
He didn't go like, Herm.
Herm.
Janelle.
It suits him way too much.
Bruno.
My last name's Gibb.
Oh, cute.
My name's Colum.
Colum.
So what now?
4G time?
Right.
Oh.
Like a fuego sauce and ass play sounds like a great combo.
Good point.
Anybody had another packet of that stuff?
Are we really thinking about that?
Wait.
See?
Everything's good.
We're all good.
Hello?
Hit the truth.
I'm the guy behind the desk.
It's the achievement I just got.
Good vibes.
I can't believe his name is Bruno.
made mint phantom that's minto minto my name bruno oh oh oh
my gosh wait
run dmc you know they came through a wall but they did the
whole song i hate the world today you're so good to me i
know that i can change i can't change i tried to tell you
but you look at me I'm an angel underneath In the same tan
sweet Like sweet and sour soft Oh sweet and sour soft This
is the lady in the song of me You must have been relieved to
see the softer side So so soft I can understand how you
could be so confused I don't envy you I'm a little bit of
everything We'll sing this Friday karaoke I'm a bitch My
name's Robert Such a bitch Sorry to anybody named Robert.
I'm sorry to anybody named Robert.
I'm such a fucking bitch.
I have no hopes, I have no dreams, and a tiny little thing.
And it doesn't even function anyway.
Because I've been wrecked at this function.
Take me as I am.
Just tiny little bitch.
Oi!
No, Rob!
I'm so sorry, Robert.
Rob.
Going to extremes, tomorrow I will change And today won't
mean a thing Poetry, I'm a bitch, I'm a lover, I'm a child
I'm a mother, I'm a sinner, I'm a saint I do not feel
ashamed I'm your head, I'm your dream I'm nothing in between
I love this world, we do this every other way I'm sorry?
That's so hard Sorry.
Fuck!
What's what happened?
I'm a...
I'm a prodigy.
I'm an editor prodigy.
I do airbase too.
I do air drums.
I'm fucking the Jackson 5 by myself.
Number 3.
Lift off.
I'm a... Oh.
Oh, my bad.
It's easily swappable for Frogbert.
I could never say that about him.
I think it's cool.
You do.
strong, bad energy.
It really does.
Don't try to save me.
So my brother, this song, his name's Robert, he loved it.
It's very tough.
I'm a mother, I'm a sinner, I'm a saint.
I do not feel ashamed.
I'm your help, I'm your dream.
I'm nothing in between.
You know you wouldn't want it any other way.
I'm a myth, I'm a phantom, I'm a myth.
I'm a myth.
on my knees when you get hurt when you suffer i'm your angel
undercover like shaft i've been numb i'm relieved can't say
i'm not alive or leave that would be good to leave uh any
other way you're not alone any other day leave with the pain
that vacation huh I think I just gave him the mic and said,
all right, do your thing.
You got to get a new Z-Team guy because, like, I'm fucking,
I'm like opening for Taylor.
Taylor?
He's a Swiftie.
He's an improv comic.
I love improv.
I saw, what's his name?
The guy who voices Sonic in the movies.
Ben Schwartz.
He does improv and I went and saw him once.
That was so funny.
Yay!
Oh, I forgot to click this.
Oh my gosh.
You and 20% of players told the Z team you were just Robert.
I'm really...
Sorry, some of my choices are quite unconventional, it
seems.
You and 59% of players chose to go on a second date with
Mandy.
20% should have been honest.
What?
What a different experience or what!
Do you want...
Wow, we would have never learned that his name was Bruno.
You and 40% of players told Chase they would kill Shroud.
Yeah, and I'd pick that again.
What are the chances of...
Of what?
Of studio send VAs to karaoke and just...
I think that's honestly what they did.
I've been watching this stream up to this...
To part where the team...
got tacos because of my partner.
I decided to get Taco Bell.
So thank... That's why I'm feeling tacos.
She's not like other girls.
You and 75% of players held your own against the red ring at
the Sardine?
We sure did.
We don't do group think here.
We don't think.
I just click something.
You and 74% of players saved the Torrance Middle School
Talent Show.
You and 42% of players chose to send the ground team to the
rescue.
I mean...
We only have, we got rid of our other flyer.
Invisigal was my most sentiero.
I performed better than, um, 50-50, baby.
Invisigal was most successful.
Alright, this out, that was four and five.
There's eight episodes, right?
If I'm remembering correctly.
Visit, Visi is growing up.
I mean a visit gal is growing on you eight episodes so we
did four and five I wonder if I should do the rest hmm we do
the next the last three on Wednesday eight is a long one one
more then oh okay
8 is a little longer.
You don't want to pause at 6.
Wait, what do you mean?
6 has a cliffhanger.
So then maybe...
Yeah, 6 to 8.
Maybe 6 to 8 then.
I don't think a cliffhanger is a spoiler, guys.
I don't think so.
I think it's okay.
So then we'll stop, we will, we will, but then it's kind of
exciting to kind of want you to come back to watch the next
stream if I stop if I do six.
Eight is very long.
Six is a cool place to end it.
I'm gonna just, the only thing is I'm hungry, but I guess we
could do six.
we could do six your dodge powers are insane tonight wait
what did i dodge the spoiler did i dodge a spoiler or did i
dodge me saying the the numbers that you guys are trying to
get me to say because you're children you're all children
i'm i'm i've been 19 a long time and i'm wiser than all of
you i'm still in my teens she's too powerful get me you
can't get me what if I don't do this often I don't order
food often but maybe I'll order I just wanted a taco what if
I go get a taco what if you guys give me 15 minutes to get a
taco I'll leave the stream up and then we Come back and we
do episode six.
How about that?
I'm a big girl.
I'm a grown-up.
Yeah, sounds good.
Okay, let me put on some music.
I'll put on...
Let's see.
I will go get a taco.
Wait, hold on.
I'm going to dress this up a little bit.
Taco.
This should be like 15 minutes.
It's not very far.
VOD watchers don't skip anything.
Wait, I could have a countdown.
But if it takes me longer, maybe people will think it's...
Well, no, I'll do a countdown.
Talk about... I'll do a countdown.
Talk about taco tuesday let's go oh my gosh it is tuesday
you're so right
extra bone
it's so small
wait wait wait wait oh
hold on i'm i'm fixing it i'm fixing it i'm fixing it
uh and then let's Let's do...
Oh no, thank you so much for the 50!
Timer!
Let's do...
Oh, let's also do this.
Let's add like a cool effect on it.
What should we add?
Let's see.
Let's add this one.
Whoa!
No, no, no, I want it to be...
Actually, let's do...
Is there a matrix one?
Oh my god.
Oh, well, thank you so much for the 50, isn't it?
Thank you.
It looks ridiculous.
Okay, timer.
Countdown.
From...
Taco Funds!
Thank you!
Wait, I have to...
Countdown, countdown.
15 minutes.
I believe, I believe.
And, uh...
Uh...
I'm wasting so much time doing all this.
Alright.
Oh my gosh, imagine if I forgot to repeat the music too.
Taco colored super thank you!
Countdown!
Oh, why does it say draw?
Why does it...
Oh, oh, oops!
There we go.
We're doing Fox on it!
Okay, I'll be right back everybody!
I'll be back.
I'll be back!
Be good.
Were you guys good?
Little iBooz?
Were you?
Were you good iBooz?
Yeah?
Scattering!
No!
Why are we scattering?
What did you do bad?
Confess.
Confess your sins to Minky.
I cheated and watched Twitch.
I don't know if there's any forgiving of that one.
Yay!
Oh wow!
We just got some...
Some ridders.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Hello, hello.
I'm going to eat my taco a little bit while the counter
still goes down.
Actually, I got a crunch wrap, Supreme.
It's not even a taco.
I have to get something fast!
Taco Tuesday, everybody!
Yippee!
Yeah, taco!
I guess let's just get into the next game.
Or next chapter, I mean.
Can I have one to taste test?
How is it?
Chomp?
What was that?
Why did my computer do that?
That scared me.
What was that?
Oh, it was the timer.
Draw.
Scared me.
All right.
Let me turn off the music and let's get back into it, guys.
I will be eating my food, though, while we do this, so just
a heads up.
Just a heads up.
Let's go!
We're deleting all your files for being...
DD!
What do you mean?
Movie game.
Yeah, baby.
I can...
I don't know.
I can't eat and...
One of the three tacos contained a bomb.
I'll tank it.
Hey everybody, I appreciate you coming to see this.
Your support means a lot.
Can't believe you actually hung out with those fuckers.
You jealous, old man?
Of what?
Let me guess.
You get into a bar fight?
I'm right, right.
That's what criminals do at bars.
They ruin everybody's fun.
Fact.
If you're gonna make me stand next to a criminal, you could
have been- You missed 3 a.m.
Tacos.
You did not make me stand next to Benjamin's fucking butt.
and you could at least change his well what you miss was 3 a
.m tacos leading to 4 a.m heartburn followed by 5 a.m
diarrhea and to spread out chat it was lovely okay photo
post test 19 ready to open face sandwich to the taco
discussion is it engaging purpose now
are you guys having deep conversations without me
Salute!
Oh wow, you actually get to pick your like, your emote.
Metal gear.
Maybe.
Not bad, right?
So far so good.
The smoke is a little overkill.
I thought the same too, but I think the purple is a nice
touch.
What smoke?
Shut it down!
Oh!
Wait, it's not supposed to be there.
Oh my god.
Let's get him out.
Eject, eject!
Uh-oh.
So loud, oh my god.
Do I still have dispatch duty today?
You chose the wrong pose.
Yeah, can I go all in sick?
Is it disrespectful to eat this taco?
No, Rod!
How long was I out?
About 14, 15 hours, I think.
Imagine if he said 16, 17 hours.
Why would it look worse than me?
It's over, brother.
Oh!
I cannot recreate the Astral Pulse.
No.
Too much power.
Too small size.
It's in the dog.
I can't make the man Mecca.
I'm not good enough, bro.
Fail you.
I failed everybody.
Almost bring down the...
No, it's just a minor setback.
Almost get you.
Let's get everybody blown up.
All this is is just a minor setback.
I'm not worried.
but I am oh Roy oh you did your best I can't ask for
anything else thank you oh
oh oh
I heard that big bastard crying in the bathroom makes it
hard to shit when somebody doing that next to you you know
pretty distracting yeah everyone else okay and busy girl
fine one thing she's good at is disappearing when people get
hurt what's your deal with her she's in the room right now
isn't she wait but she's been holding her breath extra with
vizzy she's a liability and one of us needs to be right
behind me she's in our in the bed with us don't think i
don't see
She's...
She's challenging, but we're up for a challenge.
She's challenging, which requires extra effort.
Seems like a lot of extra effort.
Yeah, I just said that.
So, I don't know.
Read that however you want.
Look, just be careful, kid.
Some people did black holes.
You reach out to help them, and they just suck you in and do
whatever the...
I don't think she's been so bad recently, though.
this kind of response she's been like cool new looks screams
i know some science shit so i was with you the whole way no
come on take the day off no really i'm fine all i've got to
do is sit at a desk desk work doesn't land you in the
infirmary think about wait seriously i have to work i'll
mull it over oh my god this is my shirt it doesn't even
button up how is it not exploded
Stick to the plan if they're red ring or enhanced proceed
with caution.
She's doing the job for me.
Oh my god You really gave us a scare Turns out I'm
completely fine Just sort of time traveled several hours
into the future where I feel pretty rested.
Oh cool.
Yeah That happens to me every night.
Wish I could say the same.
How's your ship going good?
Yeah, um challenging yeah I have a whole new appreciation
for you
I'm sorry about the pulse give us some time Roy's a little
down but I'm sure we can come up with alternate power
sources no really looking forward to tonight perfect timing
yeah same yeah wait what's tonight our date is our date
tonight wait that means okay we can't go overtime guys we
got to get in and out drink this when the meds run out so
i'm not dispatched dude but i don't know if it's any more
level at a sub at sunday school oh gosh wait wait in line
for this really cool game that i'm totally old enough to
play land in what the don't look like a scalper okay we're
in guys we're in we're and time to lock in in and out huh
what you want some burgers and in and out fries blend in who
would not look like a scalper I feel like water boy is our
guy or golem waiting patiently either of them could do this
in and out 15 minute adventure
water boy boy time boy time pop down to the store help catch
or watch my sweet kitty oh why is there four people boy time
entertain while the owner is away and keep a watchful eye
time for a mud bath baby I think he can handle it all on his
own all right sorry I'm late what I miss yeah I mean not
home I'm at work oh god wait wait wait a corneus hero name
I've ever heard it's a tiger oh you talking Robert you
you've had taco shit since the sardine you've had taco shit
since the sardine right uh sure yeah wait i'm not gonna get
that right i had taco like envisagal said mate didn't you
say you could handle spicy food yes which is why this
doesn't make sense as an excuse make a new friend i'll let
them finish talking first give us the gift back no i'm still
gonna drink it i don't care if it tears a hole in my stomach
damn we were loki hoping you taught i was gonna scoop it out
of your trash after you clocked out Okay, make a new friend.
Adarin, thank you so much for the 10kip did.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Tiger, Perrin.
Oh, Hobbs.
Like Calvin and Hobbs.
Oh my gosh.
This game is making it so I can't...
Okay.
I take a bite.
We continue.
I need a napkin.
I have one.
We're good.
We're good to go.
Continue the game.
Sorry.
Oh my goodness.
Little, little, little, little.
Oh.
I knew you got this waterboy.
I was on fire.
Yeah!
On water.
You were so good, waterboy.
You were so perfect.
Good boy.
Robert, some asshole keeps hacking to my notes app.
He's fucking with all my stand-up comedy material.
I think they have access to our secure servers.
Oh, that's not good.
We're hacking.
Okie dokie.
What is this?
Oh, okay.
Oh, scary.
We gotta loop them.
Oh, my God.
Small loop.
Oh.
I forgot that these...
Please take care of them.
Okay, we don't know that one.
Yeah.
Uh...
That scared me.
What is this?
Up, up, down.
Left, right, left.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah!
Syndica, welcome to VamboShift, thank you!
Hacked.
Get hacked, Bozo.
Hello?
Yes, it's that time of month again.
Send your finest over to clean my abode.
My abode.
Oh, Karen.
Why?
Why are all these, like, so bad?
Like, they're just...
Do players or hold down the portal?
She did the best she could.
Must be a bit rusty.
She's been away from the desk too long.
I thought this was a big...
Like, why are all these requests, like, not emergencies?
I just make it look easy.
Shit, Rabbit.
You're actually cool.
He's not.
He's just been gone all day, so it seems like he is.
Let's throw this into...
And then the last one, we'll do charisma.
There's some dude, Joseph from the Abba Man.
It's weird.
Can you make it stop?
That voice He's dressed like Phenomenon
They subscribe to SDN And you do what they tell you to It's
kind of crazy Alright, we're de-escalating a fight We're
taking down the Phenomenon The Phenomenon Phenomenon
Phenomenon fan It's so hard to say And we're escorting him
off the premise.
Okay, we're going to have Punch up here.
We're going to have Coupe here.
And they're going to do their little...
Sharp as my knife.
Awesome synergy thing.
Don't dress like the man if you can't fight like him.
I mean, I'm still thinking about that.
You know what's crazy?
I think about, like, how...
Oh, the tacos.
I'm so glad I went to go get a taco.
Yeah, I'm with the big guy on this one.
I think it was both.
They just can't stop talking about the tacos.
But, um...
Oh, yikes.
Oh, we made it Bad bitch, no stopping me Yes, queen Taco
stream Takeover But I think about sometimes how Like one of
the older Like guys that played Superman In the TV show And
how Like people really, back in the day Really thought, like
children were like That's actually Superman Like that's
There is no character.
Like, that man standing in front of me is Superman.
And so a kid once brought a gun to, like, a meet and greet
thing.
And was just like, so if I shot you right now, you would
deflect this bullet.
And the man is, like, sweating.
He's like, he's like, how'd you get this gun?
Oh, my God.
And, and, um, he had to be like, oh, yeah, but if it
deflects off of me, like, it might hit somebody else, and
then they will get hurt, you know?
Like, oh my gosh, so crazy.
Superman is, like, known as, like, a cursed role because of,
like, how everything.
Let's do Charisma and She's Smart.
George Reeves.
Why did the kid have a gun?
That's a great question.
Oh, we 100% are.
Oh, probably because of the synergy.
Max Synergy!
Reached!
Reached Max Synergy with a hero duo.
Let's go!
Let's see.
You're getting an upgrade, huh?
Um, we'll give you...
Hmm.
More intellect.
Make her smarter.
No one believes me, but there's definitely a ghost in my
house.
Anybody over there good at exorcisms?
Or whatever.
Me?
I'm in the game!
It's me!
Investigate the house.
Reassure the owner that...
Um, let's see.
We'll do Waterboy, and we need someone with charisma.
So, this might be overkill, actually.
Ah, whatever.
It's fine.
Maybe I should have done Gollum.
Re-election's coming up, and we're hosting a little roast of
the mayor.
Are you trying to talk into the ghost?
SDN Hero would really round out our guest list.
They're gonna exercise you, get out of there?
No, because that's against the chat rules.
They couldn't ever.
It says roast but be smart.
Uh oh, did I entertain and be smart?
Okay, hold on, what's this one?
There's a full-on gang war happening at the warehouse.
Oh dang.
Looks like Red Ring in the Frigos.
The red ring is closing in on this biker gang.
Oh, that's actually the Frigos.
They're an e-biker gang.
Way worse.
Enhanced durability red ring lieutenant.
Stop the gang.
Oh, no, I don't reach it.
Okay, we need...
Okay, who's smarter?
Okay, fine.
I think Invisagal is not smarter.
All right, all right.
No, they're the same.
has less uh less charisma fine oh it it did reach it did
it's chill gotcha oh I see okay okay we'll do these two then
for this and then we will um do golem for the stand up
helping people is kind of nice for whatever this is when you
get paid for it once again entertain entertain yeah you
actually have this thing and his wife got the balls Oh,
dang.
I was beginning to believe Anders Tank's wife lacked both
taste and sense.
I knew the vibes were off this morning, but I couldn't tell
if it was divorce vibes or shitty commute traffic vibe.
Hey, maybe she's not going to hell after all.
Marrying someone can send you to hell.
Oh, no.
We needed to bring Malevila because she's a demon.
Let's investigate.
Wait, the homeowner says she can hear things from her
basement.
Voices.
Yeah.
We have another hour.
Investigate the pipes.
Uh-oh.
Oh, okay.
That was not great.
But I am sure I can turn this around.
Oopsie.
The faction of light needs your help to overtake the faction
of darkness.
Preferably before eight when the park closes.
LARP.
It stands for live action.
You don't know what a LARP is?
It's not a sex thing.
Okay, it's like people dressing up and playing pretend type
shit.
The ghost swan cannon ending.
So real.
Everyone's busy, though.
They can wait.
It's not very, it's not going very fast.
I'm almost done with this, by the way, guys, so you don't
have to listen to me.
No!
Crunch, crunch, and so much man i thought we had it man i
thought so too honestly oh yeah we got that another day
saved or whatever the fuck yeah okay malevolah we gotta get
your rank up girl
hmm hmm
my level up oh my gosh me doody I just saw that you're using
the profile picture I drew the one that was for everybody I
was thinking the other day I was like wow I haven't seen
anybody using it that's so sad so thank you
I never posted it it was supposed to be you screenshot it
and then you get it That's how it's, that's how I've been
doing them.
There's been people using it.
There have been.
Yay.
Um.
Okay.
I'm focused.
What am I?
What kind of...
I think maybe more vigor.
No.
I don't know.
We're already on these...
High on these ones.
Opposite of water, boy.
Who do you pair her with?
I don't...
I think she goes with the bat guy, so...
If I change my profile pick, how will you recognize me?
That's so true, though.
It's hard for me to.
She goes with water boy now?
Okay, so she needs more...
Then we'll go with combat.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
That was good.
Uh, what is this?
Mr. Van der Stank is requesting assistance.
His line of delivery bots appear to have gained sentience
and are attacking the city.
This guy has always gotten into something.
Before they reach Vanco.
Mm-hmm.
Where is that?
It's down here, right?
Oh.
Oh shoot.
Ah!
Um...
Uh...
Screw it.
We'll do the both of them.
Me old doctor used to be over here.
Technically he's a veterinarian.
Okay.
Uh, role play.
I got the physiognomy of a pygmy hippo, so we made a fine
pair.
Robbery downtown.
Suspect is in pursuit, but we need SDN to defrost the bank.
Defrost the bank?
Okay, hold on.
Uh...
party rescue the hostages of apprehend the yachties before
they get the ransom money
i'm your guy we're still cool though right
it's not a lot of mobility but
call me a bogo there we go but we flew oh my god he did it
Alright, and then we need to defrost.
Oh, okay.
I think we're safe.
Yeah.
Nice.
Not too shabby.
Not too shabby at all.
Okay.
Now what is this?
Break the ice.
Oh my gosh, another thing.
The LARP has gone wrong!
Choose a class.
A bard, because prism.
Yeah!
I'm back in mad doves today!
baby uh-huh okay what oh my gosh wait wait wait melt the
eyes there's never been a job more work for me i got this
yeah but you're busy you're busy i didn't know you'd be so
busy okay oh he's flying back we might be able oh he's got a
rest too though i think i have to coffee him okay refreshing
Oh my gosh, I forgot to do his check.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
No, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah,
okay.
We're good?
Okay.
Okay, indeed.
All right.
As soon as I click out of this, I click.
Okay.
Yeah, okay.
Somebody's about to get burned.
Oh, okay, uh, and it's not the meme.
Uncertified forklift driver dropped an entire shipment in
the harbor.
Recover what you can before it becomes waterlogged.
That doesn't sound so great.
Maybe...
Invisigal?
Oh, sure.
And...
Uncertified.
No way.
No, you're an uncertified hamster!
You can't be uncertified for it!
The forklift driver, too!
Waterlogged, yeah, but Waterboy is...
He's resting.
I don't know if we'll make it in time.
Listen, it would bring your kid to work day, and I thought
he could try using the forklift.
We'll do them both.
I have a lot of people, so I can send them...
Oh my god.
This looks like a job for a janitor.
Let me squeeze on in here.
Catch up to the retreating delivery bots.
Reprogram them not to attack humans.
while keeping their sentiancy.
Oh, shit.
Maybe I should have sent...
Wait.
Coupe!
Coupe can do it.
She can do it.
I believe.
Close your eyes.
You're not gonna like what you see anyway.
Alright.
Too much Faito in the team.
No, no, no.
We're okay.
X.
No, she didn't.
It didn't bounce.
I didn't see it bounce.
That's why...
Wait, did it bounce?
I didn't see it.
It didn't.
Like, you guys are...
You guys are scaring me.
I have no one that's smart.
One guide.
I definitely wasn't a one guide.
It was definitely... Yeah, 50 guide.
Yeah, a ton of people were saying I I hit it.
A ton of people were saying I hit it.
Let's send the girlies out.
I thought you said you had it.
No, no, that was me.
Do I look different?
Come on!
Well, I'll be drawing yours on Sunday with the...
I bought the booze.
Folks down for a carpool?
I got rude.
I would like a ride.
I'll bring extra towels.
Happy!
Thank you!
You caught the edge but it didn't bounce.
That's what I thought.
Hero training.
Oh, let's do punch-up.
Hey team, Blazer's doing a speech over the college.
And one of you will be there to hear it.
Oh.
No?
Why is it X'd out?
Oh, maybe not.
Maybe nobody will hear it.
Wait.
huh that's funky
you haven't unlocked his og skill seriously oh my god i
can't even send him out uh let's do combat let's do more
combat he's tough guy and then for you we'll do more This is
slightly tricky, is it?
That's okay.
Let's do...
Not intelligence.
We'll do...
Oh yeah, I said I would do more charisma.
Yeah.
Let's see how this went.
I'm scared.
Oh, it did bounce!
No!
Wait!
It went...
What?
No, okay, though.
Is it because Kubei was in the first slot?
I think...
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
It didn't say it before.
It really didn't.
It didn't, though.
Is it because I put her in slot one?
I needed to put her in the other slot so that it...
Because I think...
I think what happened is...
Is, uh...
no though okay maybe it did the first time and i didn't
notice because when i put her in the second time it
definitely did not i looked we need to rewind the blood
i think that it didn't account for the boost in her combat i
think when putting her in the first slot i think that's what
it was
the buff after the fact yeah i think that's what it was um
oh well
disrupted oh yeah baby i really did look for it the second
time though when i re-put her back in there i really didn't
see it um there's an entire race of mole people.
If we... Kindness is charisma.
We got this.
The mole people.
Let's see.
I clicked it!
I'm not...
I mean, it's not because we're...
Dang.
I tried to click it to get the...
No!
Oh well.
I maxed my career rank.
Let's go!
Bring back a hero from downed.
I don't think I've ever had someone downed before though.
I think I'm too good.
Mobility too?
Cool pay.
Yippee!
Flambé has a really bad skill for a second one.
choose two are they both bad ouch
ouch i mean you know it feels like for the first time in a
long time i can see a life without mecha man which i'm sure
you would appreciate been nice that we get to spend more
time together so hard right teaching people to be heroes
guiding them it's not nothing but i don't think i can sit on
the sideline I worked hard to get good at being mecha man
incomprehensible I don't know that I want to just walk away
from that
Thank you, Russ.
Just when I feel like I got a handle on it Got it figured
out.
I think about chase And my dad and shroud Then I get all
fucked up You know what I'm saying, beef?
You know what I mean Yeah Oh.
Yeah, exactly.
See, this is why I appreciate it.
That's a chihuahua.
That's so concerning.
This doesn't seem so good.
Oh, hello.
Are you decent?
Definitely a house that needs some warmth.
I'm in my underwear.
Somehow the worse.
I am in my underwear.
I can see you.
I was joking when I asked if you're decent.
I know I just need you to know that I know how I look right
now All right, that rubs out by the way.
You just have to put a little muscle into it Do you know why
you want to hang this?
Why are you holding a lamp?
I think he's only considered where he'd hang himself That
corner seems fine It's a housewarming gift for your
housewarming party Housewarming party Wait, wait people more
people are coming here to my home Look, I'm not really in a
party mood right now tidy whities okay she just touched my
this is your family photo area kind of morbid what I didn't
tell them that I'm mecca man are they all gonna find out you
figured it out brother the man can be mecca again they're
all gonna know now wait I had this feeling like I'd seen it
before then Vizia asked me to get this morning and
cross-reference with recent calls wait wait wait wait it's
not and a bunch of B-grade villains have been trying to
unlock its power only to end up blowing their asses off like
you did.
Then they sell it on the next sucker.
They're just doxing me!
The past hand at least four times that we've tracked.
How does Shroud not know this?
Yeah, probably think like us.
I can't believe they're like, you actually made the
incorrect choice.
You don't small fuck up, man.
You're gonna figure it out soon enough.
You actually did not make the right choice because...
The Z-teamers know every low-level supervillain in three
counties.
We track its location.
then we kick in some doors knock some heads snatch that shit
back and you'll be are we sure this will work in that time
and you're sure that this will work I've had about as much
heartbreak as I could take today no clue it's not like you
got anything better to do you make a compelling argument I
have a team to dispatch things that we got was from a boat
over here in Marina de Rey which is oh Yoni territory why
she's here first you know much about those guys thank you
Oh, my goodness.
Ask what we're in coke heads.
Skylaw, Katie runs it now.
Three generations that family's been trying to think of me.
What are they accusing you of?
You're cute.
We're gonna ask you some questions about a piece of peck
they moved.
But first, Rob gotta put on pants.
Aw, what?
But then I can't do this.
Ah!
Robert's housewarming party.
And then, uh, am I gonna get flagged for this song?
Oh wait, no.
I turned it off.
I shouldn't get flagged for anything, right?
It's my girlfriend.
Wait, wait.
Isn't tonight my day with my girlfriend?
Everybody get out!
Mandy!
Uh-oh.
Wait!
Everybody leave!
Uh-oh.
No!
Oh my god.
Are you okay, Waterboy?
She was talking about the...
She was talking about this?
Is she gonna come over?
Ah!
Oh my god!
even golem could fit in the house oh oh oh oh oh
is that a salt lamp why are we dancing with it though why
aren't you licking it
they really make it feel like that there's only these people
in this whole entire company oh my god is he doing the robot
oh Ooh la la!
You do understand how projectors work.
She's just drawing that on the wall.
And bare walls are a sign of depression.
Why isn't always a warehouse by the box?
I have many walls.
It's where stuff comes in and stuff goes out.
I guess I'm not depressed.
You're a rocket scientist, are ya?
No.
That was my dad.
What kind of security are you dealing with?
That's where- That was my dad because I'm- Oh, I am Becca,
man!
like to you guys before I'll go can't shoot what you can't
see look this is really great work but doing this tonight is
out of the question hitting a secure location like this is
something they would handle downtown are you kidding there's
enough firepower in this room to take down a fucking kaiju
she repents please y'all wouldn't make it past the front
door no one's asking you to do a goddamn thing okay hey no
need for that we take the day to plan it with downtown and
hit the warehouse tomorrow night tomorrow night this thing's
not gonna sit still for that long oh we gotta go tonight I
think we gotta go tonight ready we're ready Robert no it's
not happening there's no guarantee it'll be there I think so
I think she's right she said no you understand that word or
is it got too many fucking syllables for you why don't you
go walk your ass around a mall grandpa heroes are talking
you are no fucking hero whoa hey she named you visit gal you
named yourself and visit bitch and you had it fucking right
chase you're drunk you need to stop talking you want to get
people hurt get people fucking killed then you need to go
back to the team everybody calm down everybody just calm
down this is crazy no like you but she's not Robert doesn't
need to keep I gotta record everything I was putting his
life on the line and make up for assholes like you we don't
need to be mecca man to be a hero chase please Oh wait Rob
it's Macam man.
Oh wait.
They didn't know you're playing them.
You're playing yourself You think you're invisible, but I
fucking see you You don't know anything about me.
I know you're a liar criminal.
I know you're fucking dangerous What else do I need to know?
There now I know you're a cow.
Oh my god Oh my god Vizzy wait That was a nice overcoat.
That bitch sent his ass.
So shots?
How are you not dead?
Are you doing shots now or what?
Chase already had his.
That's enough for tonight.
I'm sorry.
This turned into whatever just happened.
Anyone who utters one word about what happened tonight
fucking answers to me.
Got it?
I forgot he wasn't even here like the frogs I didn't even
realize
oh my god eating back torsions off thank you so much for the
break
yourself what are you doing oh are you in time out because
you told all my co-workers my secret identity oh that kid's
like it for the captain came back to apologize all these
goddamn apartments look the same that guy watching us from
the balcony walked into his house thinking it was yours
sorry about that fuck you hey he said he was sorry well fuck
you too why aren't you wearing clothes I was about to say
you can't let him lick the salt lamp.
Oh my god!
His blood pressure.
I was the one who suggested the ridicule.
You sure this ain't Baku.
She told you?
Made quite a first impression.
Be no, be no!
Kinky shit.
It's that internet somehow made sex boring.
Okay, now you sound how you look.
Another thing I can't do anymore.
Fuck.
Maybe it's why I say the word so much.
Uh.
oh sorry chase i hadn't thought about that why do you just
you can't yeah but think about why we do what we do help
people put it all on the line for someone who won't ever
know your name it's the right thing to do it's just the
right thing to do sure and you think the z team will be able
to tell the difference that first week Busy?
I was gonna walk off the team.
You know, she's feeling low.
Talking about how she was born with powers that always meant
she'd end up as a villain.
I don't understand.
Like he was fated.
Like, invisibility is like the most common superpower.
Why would you be like, I got the bad pick of invisibility?
Yada, yada.
That means I have to be a villain.
I do remember thinking.
Like, what?
oh the fuck yeah that must have been hard like if i didn't
have you you know you're my dad where would i have ended up
you were always good that was always in you is what makes us
different from a thief like her fantastic four don't exist
incredible what you racist motherfucker i never stole a
thing in my entire fucking life chase you've literally
stolen things from me oh oh yeah but that doesn't count that
was for somebody else
oh right you quietly contemplating robin hood over here yeah
i guess i hadn't considered some things but i think the
answers are out there if you just listen to the wind
oh you and beef get along oh where's my guy beef stop
chewing that i'm sorry my poor boy no that's it there's my
boy there's my good boy who's a good boy beef is beef heavy
how can you lift him uh-oh what's happening uh-oh what's is
the beeping sound uh-oh is there a mic on this hey hey can
you hear me the fuck are you doing oh not much them for your
stupid ass pulse that's somewhere on this big oh they went
this room must have dropped a pain in the super villain
group chat because this place is crawling with dipshits oh
my god good news is they don't know where it is either you
know who's not good beefy boy you know who's a real oh my
god you're disappointed I'm disappointed I'm sure chase will
have some shit to talk but I'm here and this is our last
chance of getting this thing uh oh okay maybe if I can hack
into the she's the only way to win oh my god check the
something would be great yeah let's start with something
she's like yelling as if like they're not gonna be able to
hear her okay still got it oh how do I do this again uh out
of range out of range oh what's this up up up up right up up
right right yeah oh oh uh uh got it hey i'm getting a huge
energy reading coming from the wave links right yeah i'm
supposed to know where that is see that tower the biggest
one it's at the top oh perfect so you want me to cross this
active battlefield look i didn't want you to do any of this
i get it okay jesus i'm gonna go in oh keep your eyes peeled
for invisibility looks like she
Shit, they're onto me.
Uh-oh.
Oh, hey, there's a door to your left.
Fuck.
It's locked.
Feel free to take your time.
Just catch up with me.
Oh, look!
Okay, I'll take my time.
La, la, la, la.
Oh, you can see them fighting there!
That's crazy!
Almost got it.
Oh, shoot.
Uh.
I got you.
Hold on.
One second!
I think I can use this.
Hurry up!
I'm working on it!
Sorry.
One second.
Uh, one second.
Uh, left, left, up, right.
Left, left, up, right.
Wait, how do I get it back over there?
Oh, oh.
Left, left, up, right.
There we go.
My bad.
I would arrive in.
That was cool!
What the fuck?
Smashed.
Flattened.
This fucking guy.
Okay, hey, busy.
Lead him towards that speaker tower.
I've got an idea.
One, but a good one.
Oh my gosh, okay.
Okay, um...
Wait, oh shoot, I went the wrong way.
At the tower.
Do your thing.
Okay.
I'm working on it.
Work faster!
Ooh, time is fast.
time is fast in this oh gosh okay uh okay uh oh shoot what
do i need wait what do i need oh oh this maybe okay uh oh
wait uh wait uh i'm getting lost in the sauce wait uh oh
here oh just kidding just kidding
cross like that it's hard for me to visualize what's going
on oh scary is that why birds fly in the shed busy look out
behind you oh my god crisscross applesauce how am i supposed
to get around that look just worry about not dying i'll
cause you a way around it
Nice.
Okay, uh, I'm working on it.
Give me it.
Why does the crane have the hardest controls?
Oh.
Why me just passing through?
Left, left, left, right.
Ah!
Oops.
Uh, shoot.
Yes.
Oh, wait.
What did I just do?
Ah!
Wait!
Sorry.
It's scary for you.
Oh my god, I don't think I'm gonna make it, you guys!
Okay, I'll kill this guy if he comes to me.
Yeah.
What was I doing?
Oh, uh, left, left, left, right.
There we go.
Now the crane.
So scary.
Heads up.
Lights here.
Whoa!
Yeah!
Ow!
The captain's quarters should be right in front of you.
Uh-oh.
Tell us where the pulse is, if it's a bitch, before we go
full Pompeii on your ass.
Full Pompeii on my ass?
What kind of threat is that?
Are you gonna give me diarrhea?
Wait, no.
That was predictable.
Huh?
Oh, I don't think... Okay, I think you should...
Where the fuck is this thing?
Because that's not gonna hold me down.
Yeah, I don't think you could... That'll work.
The safe?
I don't know how to open a fucking safe.
Fuck.
I don't have confidence in you for the last one!
What the heck?
I didn't say this was excessive but...
You have to have confidence in me!
You almost through the door!
You have to have a confidence!
Oh, shoot.
Oh my god.
Oh.
I ran running him.
Well, okay.
You got to have confidence in me, okay.
Where else I'll cry.
Okay.
Let's...
Oh my god.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
This is hard.
Wait a second.
This is really hard.
Oh.
Oh!
Ah!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Okay, wait.
Uh, no, no, no, no!
I need just not one guy to attack me, please!
I got an achievement, but I don't know for what.
Please, don't attack me.
I need, like, one guy to not attack me.
Okay.
Alright, hold on.
There's a thing here.
Oh, shit!
Oh my god.
Wait, did I run out?
Oh, shit.
There's no more.
Please!
Oh.
Okay, that's fine.
I just need...
I can...
I'll be okay.
Maybe.
Yeah!
Woo!
All right.
Case open.
Is it in there?
I'm glad to be wrong!
Yeah!
Uh, you know what?
I guess it does.
Okay.
So now...
Who kind of thief doesn't know how to open a safe?
You're so right.
Uh oh.
Holy shit.
Are they?
Robert, what's going on?
I'm here.
Just hang on.
Trying to get the camera back online.
Um, that doesn't count.
I see you.
You're good.
Just take one step at a time.
Um.
Uh.
Ooh.
Parasma.
Oh my god!
Stop!
Shroud, behind you!
Don't tell her to stop!
Tell her to run!
He's behind you!
Hey, Lizzie.
Stay calm.
Your inhaler is-
Don't tell her to stop!
Tell her to run!
Uh-oh.
Oh, that's so mean.
Hey, Vizzy, he's just going to keep fucking with you, but
you don't give up.
Okay, that's not how asthma works, I think.
I think people actually die from asthma when they don't have
inhalers.
Please.
Vizzy, hey, listen to me.
You get up.
Get up.
Oh, not the dog.
Keep up.
No!
He's gonna...
He's gonna die if he uses his powers anymore!
Okay, yeah, you're good.
Chase!
Why is this...
Oh, fuck.
Where's my keys?
Where's my fucking keys?
Wake up.
No, no, no, I'll fucking do this, please.
Please, please.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Looking over at him doing the pose and I'm gonna be like,
keep up.
Oh no.
Oh my gosh.
There's your cliffhanger.
Oh my god.
Use his powers for her.
They just fought.
Oh my god.
Now we wait for one week?
No.
I'm going to be playing on Thursday.
So you only have to wait a day.
Day and a half, really.
You and 29% of players were ready to send the Z team to
retrieve the Astral Pulse.
Oh, dang.
Not many people.
I felt confident in us.
I think we have a good team.
I've been a good dispatcher.
I think everybody else sucks if they don't think we have...
If they have no confidence in being able to take it back.
That's what I think.
I've been a great dispatcher.
The 71% weren't locked in.
I was ready to do it.
Ooh, the music.
You and 69% of players help them visit Gal, locate the
Astral Pulse.
What else were the other people doing?
You and 39% of players dance with blonde blazer.
I can't say her name very well, but...
Yeah, baby, we're dancing with her.
You and 21% of players saluted.
You and 63% of players failed to deal with Van Gogh's
delivery bots.
Epsi!
45% of players befriended the mole people.
27% of players played as the bard.
Not a very popular choice, I guess.
Fun fact, the route Chase takes through the city is not the
fastest one.
He kept taking corners.
He was enjoying his last ride.
Your most set hero was Waterboy!
I performed better than 60% of players in today's shift.
Look, read it and weep, everybody.
Successful hero was Waterboy!
Yeah!
Everybody who doubted him.
Everybody who doubted him!
Peer upon how fierce he is and how cool.
Waterboy the goat!
Salmi, thank you so much for the freedom breaks!
Hello, hello!
We are actually just finishing up though.
So, thank you guys for joining me for episodes 4, 5, 6.
Right?
4, 5, 6.
Hold on, I'm getting my thing ready.
And then, on Thursday, we will finish the game.
Oh, shoot.
With the last two episodes.
I think I saw...
Hold on.
Oh, my gosh.
So...
I'm gonna show you guys real quick how...
Okay, hold on.
No, it's gonna be kind of a...
Shut up, I can't think.
I'm trying to do like a redirect.
I thought I saw...
Phoebe was streaming.
But I subscribed to some channels that I watched the live
cams of, and I realized I didn't actually subscribe to them
yet.
maybe she was recording something um but anyway i subscribed
to them and now my so on the back end of youtube it's really
horrible trying to find somebody to to to raid into and um
live cams yeah like i have a live cam of like some deer and
i have a live cam of anoshima and i have a couple live cams
of mount fuji that I that I watch um and so I um I was like
oh I watched these like literally every day but I never rate
or I never uh subscribe to them I sometimes I just forget
even though I watch something a lot like forget to subscribe
I'm the worst I'm one of those people that's like needs the
reminder to like and subscribe because I because I forget to
do it and so I subscribed to one of them and this channel
has a bajillion so they have a bajillion live streams
happening at once so when you go to the redirect tab in
YouTube basically you have to it says like search videos for
from other channels and it kind of gives you like it says
videos from your
this one channel has so many live streams happening at once
and I'm okay this one two three four five times one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten ten so they have at
least 50 it has completely consumed my my tab so I can't
even i can't even like see who is live i would have to
search person by person it's kind of terrible she said the
thing oh whatever
but yeah so i'm like uh i think i have to unsubscribe so
that i can so that i can see people to raid into who's
actually streaming i'll have to unsubscribe you were dodging
so well i gave up it's okay i i did it on purpose i gave you
your one make a sub account just to follow that channel i do
it's just like oh my gosh um too bad there isn't a sort by
viewers or something it's it's i it's really a no i don't
know it's like so i'm like what the heck i just wanted to
support the channel because i I literally watch it every day
I watch their and the worst thing is as I only watch one of
their live streams one of their live cams because it's my
favorite one and so I'm like I don't need to see all of
these other ones thank you so much for the part get it the
tokusatsu channel tokusatsu oh my god before I subscribed to
this channel that was the other one that was making it
really difficult for me to find people to to raid into
because it was also they have so many live streams happening
at once there was so many that was that were taking over i
couldn't see it's really like it's not very intuitive
feature at all so insert picture of walter white in the back
of his car man the schedule isn't on twitter it's only on
youtube right now man thank you i did that on purpose though
but thank you for the reminder um uh i i i try not to like
post too often in a row because it's bad for the algorithm
or whatever so i wanted to wait until after stream to to
upload it but thank you for the reminder
i i have a method to my madness usually usually there is a
there's a if you're like I wonder why Mint hasn't done this
thing.
Usually, there's a method to my madness.
Or I just forgot.
Did you get your Miffy Uniclone stuff?
I did!
I did, I did, I did.
Miffy!
I love Miffy.
Ah, Twitter things, I know.
Oh, her mind is an enigma.
i definitely recommend tokusatsu if you want to watch like
common rider uh other like tokusatsu stuff
very awesome very awesome
but um i see that doki is streaming so we can raid into her
she is playing
god of war so if you would like to watch god of war Oh, you
can head on over there.
Have you caught up on Zets yet?
No.
I'm the...
Oh, wait.
Shoot, I have to search Doki.
Okay.
I...
Wait.
Doki.
Okay, it does show up.
Oh, my gosh.
It's so terrible.
Such a terrible system.
Thank you for the stream.
I wonder if your Robert Robertson, son of Robert, is the
Femememememem, the son of Fememememama, food for thought.
Fememememama, Fememama is so much easier.
to say than for mama man I'm lucky I will finish work just
before the bamboo profile picture drawing on Sunday can't
wait yeah see then Phil we're soaring welcome to membership
thank you rolls easier for mama mama for mama ma'am for mama
man for mama man
the world is full of mystery 21 months Darkies Oh, thank you
Thank you, thank you, thank you I love my most successful
hero Is Waterboy Let's go There's If you've never watched
Joel Haver's skits They're very He plays like the awkward
guy character I don't even know if it's a character honestly
He just He plays it so well So they're pretty funny Some of
his stuff Hmm Yeah, I love his skits.
They're really funny.
Oh, yes, animations, too.
They're so goofy.
He was in Smiling Friends, too.
All my YouTube Oshis are in Smiling Friends.
I really need to watch more of it.
Ghost.
Oh, my gosh.
21 months of I-Born.
I-Born.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I missed your tacos.
Hope they were good.
They were great.
I'm nice and fool.
You should watch Smiling Friends with Barry.
Yeah.
I didn't know she liked it.
Oh, wait.
Yes, I did.
I didn't know she liked it.
I'm a liar.
And a thief.
And a ghost.
Otavito, everybody.
Thank you so much for hanging out with me today.
I will see you when I see you next.
And get some tacos.
Tacos, tacos, tacos.
tacos tacos tacos tacos tacos tacos it's time for tacos it's
time for tacos it's time for tacos bye bye thank you thank
you thank you bye